we're not equipped to deal with
what's happening in the world so the way
we get through it is through connection
hi I'm David Cho and you're listening to
the Rich Roll podcast
[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast
my guest today is a guy who has
fascinated me for years his name is
David Cho he's a street artist he's a
fine artist a muralist he's also a
writer a podcaster a television host and
a recovering sex and gambling addict and
although highly flawed like all of us
are just a refreshingly honest open
vulnerable sensitive caring and and
really beautiful human the inspiration
for reaching out to David In This Moment
is his latest creation it's called
chosho on FX it's this limited series
that I'm absolutely obsessed with it's
unlike anything you've previously seen
on television just this explosion of
creativity and honesty and vulnerability
all wrapped in a sort of talk show
format as you is the man himself
if you're already familiar with David
perhaps you caught him on Howard Stern
or Joe Rogan or Dave Chang's podcast all
absolutely wild conversations worth
checking out by the way David is nothing
if not very entertaining but today's
conversation I think is qualitatively
different in so many ways a version of
David as perhaps you have never before
seen him and really very focused on
things like mental health childhood
trauma addiction sobriety and more
broadly this journey he's been on
towards self-acceptance and self-love I
adore this conversation it's quite
unlike any I have had previously on Mike
and mostly I hope you find it helpful
especially if you're one of those people
who is suffering right now
and I think that's just about all I want
to say about what's to come so please
click that subscribe button and enjoy
what I think is a very meaningful and
beautifully heart-centered conversation
with the singular David Cho
it's really nice to meet you man nice to
meet you too I've uh been looking
forward to this for a while and uh
as somebody who's kind of followed your
trajectory Arc for a while
um just delighted that you would agree
to come here I have to say I was really
surprised when you dm'd me because I was
saying stuff about you know the show and
and you on the podcast and when you
reached out I was like thrilled so
um I'm excited to talk to you and you
know typically with these things like I
do a ton of research and I come like
loaded to bear with all these questions
and and thinking about like how to
approach this with you like I I honestly
like
I was like I can go down some crazy
rabbit hole and learn everything I can
possibly learn about what you've shared
publicly but you know I really just want
to be
present with you like I want to do a
little bit of what it was like what
happened and what it's like now and I
guess I'm really interested in in like
this growth trajectory that that you've
been on
um I think it's really fascinating
it's impressive I think there's so much
wisdom to be mine that could be helpful
to other people because it's been a
[ __ ] journey man that you've been on
uh yeah well I guess I should start with
um full disclosure I don't have social
media so the person who dm'd you was was
my assistant yeah all right
um fair enough man I appreciate the
honesty well you know like
I have I am aware that I have a social
media presence but it's it's not me like
that yeah is that for self-preservation
oh absolutely yeah it's the it's it has
added
um you know I can't sit here and say
it's added nothing to my life because
it's I use it as a promotional tool and
get get my message out but
um negative feedback and especially
positive feedback doesn't help me you
know so I I have a child
um blocked phone so I I don't have
access to those things so if I want to
write something or reach out to someone
I send it to my assistant and he reaches
out and
um I appreciate
um you know in in my days where I did do
podcasts I would do the same I would I
would do as much homework and be as
prepared as possible and I just
[Music]
um
there's I I don't know if you can tell
but like I'm very intimidated to be here
because like you shouldn't be dude you
shouldn't be I am and I'll tell you why
but you see I will say you seem really
like chill and grounded like I meditated
yeah like the maniacal like high energy
like high wire act dude that like we're
kind of accustomed to
um I meditated in the IHOP parking lot
uh before I came here and for about 30
minutes and
you know when I do these things I don't
do them very often anymore yeah I never
know how deep I'm gonna go so my brain
um marks where all the fast food places
are so I know getting off the freeway I
know I saw the Burger King the
McDonald's the Jack-in-the-Box IHOP and
I go I don't know what's going to happen
with Rich today but depending on what
happens my brain has already planned my
how I'm gonna get high at the end of
this which is you know the fries at
McDonald's two tacos from Jack In The
Box and
part of my
part of what
um
you know I'm not an athlete you know and
as I get older I try to stay in shape
and you know doing a very poor job of it
and when I meet someone who's like a
marathon runner and in your case like
I don't even know what you call the
things you do like Ultra Mega you know
I don't
I quit anytime I have a trainer or and
they push me too hard and I start to
feel the burn or I feel something I go I
don't feel good right now like my body
doesn't like this I feel like I'm gonna
puke right now and then I just stop so
when I find someone or meet someone
who's capable of running hundreds and of
miles and all these things
there's two things one side of is
inspirational wow the human body and
then the other side is wow if this guy
is capable of this I mean he's capable
of it like it's he's probably just like
so much of that like I get uncomfortable
hearing that because so much of it is
projection and I get this a lot when I
go out in the world and perhaps you can
relate to your version of it which is oh
did you just run 20 miles or you could
have run here from your home and like
in my mind I think if they only knew
like the reality of it or how I think of
myself because the truth is right now
I'm not doing that like I'm doing
podcasts and I'm traveling and I'm
raising teenagers and I got a lot of
obligations and now I got this studio
and I have people that work for me so
there's this you know past that I have
that's somewhat current of being an
athlete and that's true I don't dismiss
that I honor that and I'm I'm I'm
grateful when people recognize that but
at the same time that's not the reality
of how I'm living right now and so it
lands kind of undeserved and the fact
that it would make you uncomfortable is
preposterous and so I would say to you
in the same way like oh my God this like
this like incredible artist is coming
here and he's like so full of life and
creativity and and any such an
incredible Storyteller and I'm nervous
like what am I going to say to this guy
that you know like that like how am I
going to help make this interesting for
other people so a lot of that is just
being human and I think it's also you
know one thing that we share is just a
history with addiction you know I've
been in recovery for a long time and I
like struggle with just emotional
sobriety every single day and like
trying to put a lid on my Character
defects and the negative kind of Loops
that you know play out in my head of
unworthiness and and undeservedness and
and all of that kind of stuff that you
know is maddening
I guess when I hear you say that my
version of that would be I remember I
went to an art school in Oakland they
changed the name but it used to be
called California College of Arts and
Crafts and I was so nervous the first
day and I was like this is this is where
all the people that can really draw in
my my background was illustration and
Comics so you know I'd tweak out and
just draw and draw so I'm like this is I
was known as the kid that can draw in my
class so I'm like this is where that kid
from every school is coming here so it's
the test of the the best and I remember
I had this illustration teacher Vince
Perez and it was the first first day of
class and we got our first assignment so
I didn't sleep for that whole week and I
and and when I joined uh when I when I
presented my assignment
two kids and I remember the names I
won't say it you know quit the class
because they were like you know if
there's people doing stuff like this
um that I'll never live up to this you
know and and they quit and that gave me
at that time so much joy I was like and
and and then later in life
um you know the way all my addictions
manifested with the one the one main
addiction where you can hide in plain
sight and no one no one will say
anything in fact they'll Pat you on the
back and say good job is workaholism so
about seven years ago when I was
you know I started to do stand up I was
having art shows Selling paintings for
you know millions of dollars
um
professional gambling I had my own
podcast I started doing the news for
vice and you know we want to Emmy that
year that I joined
um you know uh I was I was sleeping with
multiple women in a day
um I had the highest score on Angry
Birds at the time so it was just like I
I had to and I remember joining my first
like self-help group thing and you know
I'm most of the guys are older than me
and there's Titans of industry and it
was just I walked in with a less than
attitude and when I heard like oh I
started this company I did this I had to
I had to show you like oh you're you're
a workaholic let me let me like I don't
sleep I don't do drugs I don't do this
and look at all these things like
whatever you did I did a thousand times
more so you're less than me I'm more
than you and um
and and today I I don't
I like that was such a um reactive way
to live life you know yeah it's like you
do this then I do this and I gotta it
was like a it's like a game it's like
it's all it's it's all competition I
mean I've heard you talk about how you
from an early age like approach your art
from a competitive place like I don't do
Sports this is my sport how can I
outwork everybody and and and you know
behind all of that of course is this
like compulsion or drive to be seen to
be recognized that derives out of you
know the the sense of Abandonment from
when you were younger and all the kind
of like trauma that that
um
that you experienced
and it is something that Society you
know our society Smiles upon and with
that like comes the creation of the ego
right which is the Beast right right you
know as society's approving of you and
you become more and more successful and
and your self-will gets attached to that
like I did this I'm the one behind this
it becomes like
something that becomes really
unmanageable and it's not until it's too
late that you even are like in a place
where you can reckon with it
yeah I
I I tell myself all these stories you
know there's a story like
that I tell myself in my head of like
who I am and then there's stories I tell
on podcasts or writing books and then
you know like that's a narrative that
I've been telling myself for a long time
and is is it true or is that just how
you know is that my editor you've told
it so many times and you know it's going
to get a reaction right and your memory
is really of the telling of the story
and not of what actually happened and my
memory is horrible my memory is very
inaccurate and it's horrible and I just
remember
um
I remember being in so much pain and
like
it was it's both right I tend to be very
binary life's awesome our life's the
worst but it was both you know I
remember having a very happy childhood
at the same time being in like just
a lot of anxiety and pain all the time
and
and um I got
tired of people telling me I was such a
good artist you know like sometime in
high school like when I was 13 14 15
around that age and I was um you know
growing up in Los Angeles I was I was
introduced to uh graffiti you know but
you know I didn't know this at the time
but graffiti has a lot of rules there's
a lot of structure there's like this
this neighborhood you can't paint in and
these kind of letters and you know and
I'm like I didn't
I don't want to be a vandal so I could
follow more rules you know right yeah
it's ironic
you know the band Soundgarden so in the
trifecta of grunge right there it's
usually Nirvana Pearl Jam and then
Soundgarden's third and so I I used to
listen to more uh it's probably say
Nirvana but then
there's a song
um slaves and bulldozers which is like a
really long it's like seven or nine
minute song
and it's um Chris Cornell sings In
like every single octave in that song
you know he's like the lowest you and I
would just I remember being at my house
and playing it
as loud as possible I had my headphones
and I had it on uh I think I had it on
cassette or CD and I would just listen
to it over and over and I would start
um
getting myself hyped up for going out to
do graffiti and I wasn't part of a gang
or a crew or anything it was just me and
some spray paint that I stole
and um I would just listen to that song
and there's a there's a lyric in the
song where he goes now I know why you've
been shaking and I I didn't I didn't
know you know I was 15 I didn't know
what that meant but I just I love that
line and I would sing it back with them
and then I would start punching myself
in the face
soft at first and then like I just
I was so um
uh like I said my background is drawing
like you know drawings in like in a
Sketchbook like you know it's like this
like I don't you know it's very
it's my world I draw in my Sketchbook
and then I close it the idea of going
outside and painting something big that
could be judged that people would see me
it gave me a lot of anxiety so
this is the way I would get myself hyped
up and then
and then I would start like what if what
if another gang sees me you know drawing
over their stuff or what if the police
chase me or what if you know like
there's all these what ifs so I would be
be like
there's nothing you can do to me that I
can't do to myself I'll hurt myself
first I'll get myself you know so I'd
um
I get myself hyped up I I already like
um get some adrenaline going just from
like hitting myself and and then I would
go out and then I get out there and I I
just I had no idea on how to
paint using a spray can like it's one
thing to use a brush and a a pencil and
so I'd get out there
and I'd I'd freeze I'd be like I don't I
don't know what to do and then I would
just I just started writing my name
David Joe like and it was an attack it
wasn't like my alter ego and I would
just start writing it and I would um
I would like right next to it I'd draw
like a cute whale and it was almost like
prompting the police like come get me
you know but I also knew like on some
unconscious level like a cry for help
yeah exactly age right exactly yeah and
that cry just gets louder and louder and
louder as your life gets bigger It Go
very loud yeah you know it got very loud
and um
you know and and I was thinking about
that recently with um
um you know watching these people
um in Afghanistan like run onto the
tarmac and jump on the on the airplanes
while they're taking off and like
falling to their death and one of my
Character defects I've developed over my
entire life is
I have to be first in line
you know I know how to cut I know how to
lie still manipulate I know how to do
anything
that I need to do so that I don't have
to wait in line like if we're at Magic
Mountain Disneyland at the airport I
know what to say what to I I know every
trick in the book
and um
you know like when I'm with my friends
when I'm with my wife they say
why you got to do that man like what do
you got to get somewhere are you in a
hurry like
and
it's um I grew up with the stories of my
family
escaping from Korea right like you're
waiting in line to get on the boat to
get away from the Japanese and
so I wasn't I wasn't there
that never happened to me that's a story
from my grandparents from my aunts my
uncles telling me these like horrendous
stories and so I grow up uh with this
imagine thing that may or may not happen
one day right like it's like one day
there's gonna be a tank that turns the
corner right and you better be the first
on that boat and when you get there to
that line you better claw kick screen
you better do anything so because your
life depends on it you're almost like a
there's an epigenetic thing like that's
imprinted on your DNA and it gets passed
down so even though you didn't suffer
that trauma it's like part of who you
are something it's triggered in you
exactly whenever you're in a line but I
think even on top of that there's that
like varnish or like veneer of of
of of the addict and the addicts
entitlement like don't you know who I
think I am like I deserve to be at the
front of the line is that part of that
piece also
I feel so good right now talking to you
like listening to you talk because it's
like
um you know something you said at the
beginning of
like if I'm going on Howard Stern or
like
I always feel like I have to over
explain stuff or maybe talk over like
you know like I'm I'm in the world of
recovery which is not sexy and I don't
for the most part like talking about it
because I don't ever want to explain to
someone what a gambling addict is well
that's a real addiction like I so I am
kind of overcompensate and go into like
storytelling or like um
uh like a per like a cartoon character
projection of what I think I am to
people and like I feel good right now
like I don't know and you're like well
it's that thing that you learn like
people that are really funny who are
addicts like learn it's it becomes a
defense mechanism or a coping mechanism
they can hide behind the joke you know
that you're an unbelievable Storyteller
so you can always pull out that card
when you need to and get the approval or
you know if you're Stevo you can do some
crazy stunt you know and get the
attention that you need but it's really
ultimately a deflection because you're
protecting that like inner child that is
wounded or afraid of speaking their
truth
yeah and you know uh since you bring up
Stevo I had dinner with him uh about two
weeks ago
and
you know he was on my show and I I know
him casually I've met with him like he's
a friend of mine okay yeah yeah so I
don't know him too well so having dinner
without a camera on it was nice to get
to know him
and I don't think he would mind me
saying this but
even though he's not a dad he's he's got
a lot of dad he's like a dad like
he's sorry I'm like burping he's he's
very concerned about like climate change
and like the stimulus package and he's
just like concerned and I'm and I'm
sitting there going oh like he's making
all these good points and I'm like
wait what do you care like you you jump
in a shark tank like any day like every
single stunt you do you could die and
your character you're caring about like
what the you know future of the world
you know and
and uh he said hey you know
I don't think I was ever
um an adrenaline junkie you know I I
just he's like the way his addictions
manifested itself and and he would tell
you this is is he's an attention [ __ ]
right he's like all of it is so
um
and I go have you ever
you know would you ever do a stunt or
something and not broadcast it for TV or
you know like would you do it just just
for yourself just to be like I would
um and I actually had this conversation
with Rayne Wilson also it's like
everything
I've ever done that's you know
performative it is a performance it's
for someone else you know if it's almost
like if it's not filmed then it's like
it never happened right and that's
something that I really struggled with
because
my final art show was in
in Beverly Hills on Rodeo
in 2009
and um
I was so checked out at that time you
know and it was
my my gallerist
um Steve lazarides is you know he was
the same same guy that represented
Banksy and
um he's just like he's from London he's
like where do you want to do your next
show Dave and I was like it has to be in
La it has to be on the most expensive
you know the most like right in Rodeo
Drive and
you know lights camera action you know I
want every celebrity there and
it was just all like I had to show
you know everyone like I was enough and
I was not I wasn't even enough I was
better than you you know yeah and
how'd that work out
I I just sat there and I and I you know
they're they're telling me how much the
you know you sold out your show and the
whole thing and
and by that point
um you know my name was starting to be
in conversations with like Damien Hurst
and murkami and you know all these
and um and I got to meet some of these
people
and I was like
that you know they're nice guys whatever
but I'm like I don't I don't ever want
to be these people you know I don't want
to like
you know usually when you get to that
stage then you have a factory and then
you have other people painting your
stuff for you know and then you can sell
stuff you know and it just it's just
right there's there's never It's never
enough it's just more and more and more
and and I sat there and
I just kind of said to myself
um
I don't want to sell my art anymore
you know like I I don't and you know and
it goes against everything if I was
raised and like survival and getting to
the front of the line I just said
it's enough I've literally made enough
money in my life I can you know I don't
ever have to work again which is
uh every time I've said that out loud is
such a
it's abstract
it's abstract to say
I'll go one step further I never have to
move again I never have like I never
have to move again like I can hire
someone to just push me around like the
total um addict side of me that wants to
like have zero responsibilities and
accountability I can literally buy a
humongous house and have just someone
wheel me around and just all the food
and video games and you know all my
human desires and needs can just come
right to my door and I don't have to do
anything again and if I start thinking
about that it it messes me up because
yeah that's not the life I want right
you know right but you had to you had to
you know have an experiential adventure
with all of that to arrive at that place
like you had to dip your toe into every
conceivable
Indulgence but that's the thing as as as
as a human as a man like
you know I knew I had people in my life
that knew better and they were like
you know they told me they're like the
writing's on the wall like this doesn't
end well for you and yet I had to be
like but let me see for myself and the
ego goes well it didn't work out for you
right and even though you're smarter you
know more powerful more better looking
more everything than me like that's how
it worked out for you for me it'll be
different and to have more and more and
more people tell me I still have to see
for myself and
I'm not I'm not that way today if
someone's like hey that's not a good
idea I go okay yeah I'm over it so I am
I pulled the plug on the the calmer side
of my my
art business because I went back to
um
there's so much there's so much when you
tell someone or when I tell myself I
want to be an artist right it's not like
I just sit down and I start painting
it's
what is this for is this for a gallery
is this for you know a children's
storybook is this
um how much am I going to sell it for
like you know there's so much stuff that
comes with it and when I when I paint
with kids I do a lot of murals with like
at-risk Youth and stuff
there's none of that right as adults we
need a lot of explanation we need a lot
of hand-holding we need a lot of
um what what is this for and you know
there's so many questions and then like
with kids when I say I teach them it's
it's I just put the I just put the tools
I'm giving them permission yeah I just
put the tools out and then they just I
don't even expression in its purest form
so stepping outside of the Commerce
piece yeah uh you know provides that
opportunity for you to reframe your
relationship with your art where it can
be just about pure creative expression
and you being motivated only by this
sense of having something you want to
say and saying it for no other reason
right which is it's hard it's the best
that's good that's if you remove all
those other motivations right that kind
of produce the best art anyway or the
purest art but you said the word
permission which is I think is huge
because
there was an art Barn at the first
um rehab I ever went to and for me
they're like this is your life so I was
actually banned from the art Barn right
like this is the only guy yeah can't do
that they're like this is your Escape so
you're not like you gotta go do
something else but I remember peeking my
head in there and you know it was it was
a really expensive rehab so everyone in
there is like a multi-millionaire or a
billionaire and
um there was a guy in there who's you
know you could argue is one of the most
powerful people on the planet and he was
asking permission if he could use like
the glitter you know they were all using
normal paint but then there was like a a
glitter section he's like can I use the
glitter and I was like
[ __ ] you can buy this place you
can buy this place you can build your
own like and I go that guy had to ask
permission and then I I just go back you
know because for kids like young kids
they just do they just do life right
they just live life and
I think about how many things in my life
is this okay
yeah is it can I you know like there's
so much oh I'm sorry am I allowed to you
know and and and for me
it's because um
you know I was talking to Paco the
filmmaker uh who who did the show show
with me he he literally flew in uh from
the Philippines yesterday he's crashed
out at my house right now and I talked
to him at dinner last night about
um
uh pogs and um they're those like little
cardboard
you know things that that you you know I
I never played it but I guess you you
play it and then you win someone else's
pogs so
um his his father was was a he worked at
Pepsi in the Philippines and he and Paco
was playing with Coca-Cola pogs and he
was you know it was a skill that he had
to win other kids pogs and at the end of
the day he had a stack you know he had
and he was so proud of
this thing that he had done
and his dad comes home and he sees the
Coca-Cola logo and he said like like a
movie had just started raining in Manila
and it started turning into a typhoon
and his dad took all his pogs and he's
like Dad what are you doing like those
are mine yeah and he threw him into the
typhoon
and this is something that happened at
his
I don't know how old he was seven eight
and so
um you know and my version of that is
you know in Koreatown my Dad's friend
you know this is in the uh 80s early 80s
when Koreatown was much smaller
um his friend had opened a seafood
restaurant and like the way
things worked with Korean immigrants is
uh without getting too into it it's like
they would like loan each other money to
start businesses it was like support
like you start your business and we come
support you and and so I remember my dad
in the car there going like let me order
because we didn't eat out that often
because we didn't have that much money
and I know he was going to get like the
the friends and family discount but he
was like let me order because seafood
can be expensive you know
and um
I remember going you know going okay
cool and we went there and it was I
think it was my first time like at a
real restaurant and I must have been six
or seven not like McDonald's or
something
and I remember his friend you know he
was charming and he came with his thing
and he's like and you little man what do
you want you know and there was a
lobster tank and he's like the Lobster's
fresh today you know like and I I didn't
have I never had an adult asking me what
I want you know so I'm like that I'll
have that and I could just feel my dad
glaring down at me you know just like
and um so then he took everyone's order
and then as soon as he left my dad's
like
do you know how much a fresh Lobster
costs you know and and then you know my
brothers jumped in you know they're like
stupid David like you Dad said he's
gonna order now now we you know
so I'm like um
you want me to get him like should we
change the he's like you know no then
we're gonna sound like we're poor and
you know so this shame
I'm telling you a story about
a lobster meal you know so then the
lobster comes I can't even enjoy it
right does it taste good you know I'm
like I guys I don't want it now like you
guys are been yelling at me he's like no
we're gonna sit here till you finish
eating that and uh so I'm like crying
eating this lobster tail
you know cut to 20 years later
like I'm gambling millions of dollars in
Las Vegas
um having lobsters sent up to the room I
have prostitutes in the room and I don't
even eat the lobsters you know I just
check into every penthouse suite in
Vegas first thing I do when I when I
check in is two lobsters
and they're like they're like oh are you
gonna eat it now or you want to go just
send them up to the room right so
there's rotting lobsters in every
Penthouse in Vegas and I don't even eat
it it's just like a it's just like a
[ __ ] you to my dad you know like
um and I didn't even put that together
until I was in therapy and part of the
problem
is what did I just tell you about pogs
and
and um
and lobster
and I get into
I get into treatment and there's people
there that have been you know seen their
family murdered in front of them they've
you know so then I make it a competition
this guy just told me his family was
murdered like in front of him in
Cambodia and now he's here and I'm gonna
bring up a story about ordering too much
Lobster at dinner
so I don't speak up for myself so I
suppress it I push it down I go dude big
deal
I say big deal but then it manifests in
like these it it comes out sideways in
all these strange ways and
um or do I have permission yeah that's
what it comes down to do I have
permission
to forgive myself to have permission to
forgive my dad do I have permission to
eat lobster now without all this guilt
and shame do I have
and
and
um
and the answer in most cases of the
people that I've been talking to is no
so it comes out in workaholism it comes
out and like
basically saying I am not allowed to ask
for permission for what my needs are
because
I'll be rejected I'll get yelled at and
so it's like living with this ghost of
and you know if you met my dad today
he's like the sweetest guy so you know
in the same way
I go uh you know just he was an
immigrant and he had three kids and he
didn't have any money so I make I make
the excuse for him you know yeah instead
of just being like but the trauma is
what it is and it doesn't matter the the
you know the motivations behind your
parents you know all our parents on some
level we're doing the best that they
could with the deck that they were dealt
it's that Gabor mate thing of emotional
trauma childhood trauma like laying the
foundation for these errant behaviors
and the addictions that follow we can
always trace it back to something that
in most cases you know for a lot of
people it's like their parents I'm sure
your dad doesn't even remember that oh
yeah it's like it was a meaningless
thing in the moment and yet it gets
locked in in your psyche and becomes
this you know latent like pernicious
seed that that germinates over time and
manifests in all kinds of craziness
later on
it's like we all have some version of
that and that guilt and shame that we
feel
because our pain isn't as grandiose as
somebody else's our pain is our pain man
you know it's like it's not there's no
measuring stick yeah the way was
explained to me is everyone's pain is
maximum to them
so when I'm being shamed for ordering
you know incorrectly I'm not thinking oh
there's a kid down the street getting
beat up by his dad I'm just thinking in
that moment this is happening to me and
it gets locked in forever yeah
we'll be back in a sec but first if you
dig this podcast and I hope you dig this
podcast then I think you'll really enjoy
my latest book voicing change featuring
excerpts from poignant essays bi and
glorious photography of some 50 of my
favorite guests over the last eight plus
years of doing this thing this podcast
it's a gorgeous Artful compendium of the
show and copious wisdom shared therein
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table
form that provides a great taste of what
we do here at the RRP and serves as a
beautiful Keepsake or gift for the
Ardent fan the book is only an
exclusively available on our website
signed copies are available and we are
shipping globally direct to any coffee
table on planet Earth so to learn more
and snag your copy today visit
richroll.com
VC that's richroll.com
VC all right let's get back into it
I'm wondering is it uh I don't know too
much of your stories that
you know once again I don't want to the
the joke with running anyone who's a
runner is like hey so what are you
running from yeah so sure of course yeah
I mean it's it's all about your
relationship to it like in many ways I
can look at my
you know career as an athlete and and
make a checklist of all the ways in
which it's improved my life but I think
I would be dishonest if I didn't say
that there's some addictive compulsion
that that that
um that attracted me to pushing myself
in that way it's like this place that
you can go where you'll be celebrated
for going further longer harder than
anyone else and nobody's gonna bat an
eye so so there isn't it there is like a
you know an addict piece with that that
you know I'm sure there's ramifications
for you know my involvement in that
overall I think it was a good thing and
I've I had I put enough work into myself
at that point where I could like
keep you know keep it from getting too
out of control but if you go to any
ultra marathon like you know probably 70
percent of the people there are in
recovery and covered with tattoos it's
like it's it just it's like a it's like
those little lights that attract the
bugs you know it's one of those kinds of
things so who was it for you was it
mostly mom or dad or
I think it was a little bit of both I
mean it was a it was a
it was a it was a household of
high expectations being set that I could
never quite meet and my relationship
with my parents is is good now like
especially with my dad we've gone
through a lot so it's not about blaming
them or them being bad people oh no I
don't think it's about that it's just if
I try to have this conversation with my
parents they'll instantly go to that
they'll be like oh like why are you
trying to make me look I go right it's
not about that because I love my parents
and I think they're great people it's
just
um I got really really defensive when I
was in treatment because
my dad kicked the [ __ ] out of me one
time one time so in my mind I deleted
that memory and I said
um
dude there's people out there that have
like the most of my my dad sings me
songs to sleep he takes me on trip he's
great and one day he had a bad day I
don't know what happened at work I don't
but one day he did that and so the of
course the treatment team focuses on
that I'm like what's yeah why are you
guys trying to turn me against my dad
like why are you trying to get me to and
they're like
well that did something that one day did
something to you and it's not about
blaming them or it's just addressing it
you know because this is this wound
that's open let's just address it and
then and then we can move on from it we
don't have to just sit there and and
blame this thing forever you know
and um
you said this thing right now if if if
you're open to you know I heard you
describing
um you know all the sides of uh the the
emotions that come with ultra marathon
running and it's uh bringing something
up
in me when I was doing podcasting
um
so what part of this podcast is not
healthy for your recovery I mean there's
a workaholism piece to it you know it's
it's it's a lot more work as you know
somebody's done it and I think people
realize there's a competitive piece to
it like I want to you know I wanna you
know I wanna I want it to be as good as
it can be
um I want these experiences to be as as
helpful to other people as I can
possibly craft them and it's that
tension between self-will like I know if
I put a lot of in into it it can be
better and also what I've learned from
recovery which is I have to allow it
what it wants to be like I have to
surrender to it and it's actually better
the looser that I hold it
I'm always waging this war with myself
over that but there's certainly a
workaholism piece can I do more who else
can I get why is that person getting
that person and why can't I do that or
why you know like I I I buy into a lot
of that like that's a lot of my
Character defects and I can hide behind
that and while the podcast is successful
I get applauded for it
in the way that in a minimal way you
know in comparison to kind of like what
happened with you and just being
celebrated I mean I remember
when you you know way back when you were
doing that podcast DVD essay I mean it
was insane dude I was I I would tap into
it occasionally and just be like this
guy's so [ __ ] out of his mind you
know like I just can't I I was like I
can't I'd hear you on Rogan and I would
check out the podcast and I was like
this guy is on a crash course With
Disaster I don't know what the timeline
is here but I remember doing Howard
Stern and then after the interview him
taking me to off to the side and he's
like you're wild man like this is this
doesn't you know like you you better
tuck it back a little like and to have
my hero Howard Stern say I'm out of
control was like the greatest compliment
he could ever gave me and I remember
that time and everything you just said
resonated with me that's why I'm curious
is
you know you could call it my delusion
or my aspirations at that time was I'm
going to be bigger than Howard I'm going
to be bigger than Joe Rogan and my
workaholsom was at its all-time high I
was like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna trick
um Sasha Baron Cohen out to being my
show because he wants to buy an art you
know like he was looking at paintings
but then I said go go in that door over
there and like we were recording live
like reverse Punk yeah like guess I
couldn't get I would try to use my art
like every day I was sitting there and
uh my mistake was
I don't know if it's mistake everything
I guess happened the way I needed to but
when I paint I can do anything I want
it's not literal right like I can paint
an abstract painting a fantasy painting
you know some sci-fi anything it doesn't
you don't have to take it literally I
just paint and I and I have that freedom
as an artist to just paint whatever and
I brought all that energy into uh my
podcast I was like I want to use words
like pigments like paint I can you know
I'll tell a story but I'll exaggerate
this part I'll edit out this part and
this great thing that I heard from this
other guest I'll make it like it was my
story and every day it was uh How can I
you know and a bit of like just reactive
like
um you know Asians are supposed to be
like Meek and you know you know your
podcast should be about math or some you
know something like that and so I there
was a lot of I need to show that Asians
can also be crazy and not just crazy but
the craziest and so just
um
sitting there and going how
inappropriate can I make this podcast
how insane can I make it and then the
and and then you know once in a while
you know teaching some of the the
positive things that I that I learned in
life and getting you know hundreds and
then at some point thousands of people
saying I look forward to your podcast
you know I'm sure you get this you're
inspirational you did it you turned your
life around you got all these things and
um
and getting almost like this kind of
Messiah Guru complex of like I'm helping
people this podcast is helping people at
the cost of myself some martyr [ __ ] yeah
but it's okay I I can take it I can I
can take this a lot of people can't take
it I'll hurt myself so that other people
can be entertained so other people can
learn from my mistakes and I'll
sacrifice myself at this Altar and in
the same way
that I walked away from painting I just
said this isn't I'm gonna die doing this
yeah like I'm literally gonna die doing
this so I I stopped podcasting and so
it's pretty abrupt too like just you
just stopped uploading yeah it was just
um I just sat in a room one day and um
the podcasts were so um
I I just I just
you know
the ones that I had played for my
friends
in the same way
um
like I like it when it hurts right like
I imagine like
um as someone who's not ultra marathon
runner when the pain starts it's like
okay like something gets activated now
now we're honestly now we're on yeah now
it's now it's on like you know
um people were starting to have
um you know really threatening hate mail
towards me people writing articles
people trying to cancel me and now it
was actually it was like oh you thought
that was bad so then I went
and I and I you know I still have
um hundreds if not thousands of podcasts
I I lost track
and I would play them for my closest
friends and they're like you can never
upload this yeah you literally can never
no one can ever hear this and I go but
it's
I'm not doing anything I'm not I'm
literally talking using words and
they're like you're saying stuff that is
like so bizarre and so offensive and so
and I go but like
like isn't that what art is supposed to
It's supposed to make you uncomfortable
and push and they're like Dave we we
[ __ ] love you man like yeah don't
don't do that there's a difference
between being a provocateur and
Performing like a public self-immolation
like it was like this on one level like
your whole life becomes a performance or
like everything that you're doing is a
form of of media that is an expression
of your interior life but unmistakable
in that was this sense of of you I mean
a cry for help is like the wrong term
like it was more severe than that like
you were you know I wanted to die I
wanted to die it was it was clear to
anybody who had any kind of like you
know uh therapeutic background that like
you were in a lot of pain and and you
didn't you didn't you you didn't know
how to quite Express that and you were
very far away from being in a place
where you could actually raise your hand
and ask for help and so what you were
doing was exploding your life in real
time and I carried all the cliche
this is this is my problem with like
you know I didn't watch the latest
Anthony Bourdain documentary even though
I know I'm in it because I do want to
celebrate all the positive wonderful
things he did in his life but I also
know in our society the story the cliche
story is you kill yourself you're going
to be on murals you're going to be
Memorial you're going to be worse you're
going to become a demigod people are
going to worship you and I don't like
that and at that time I didn't have
you know I had very close friends that
were like there's this thing called
therapy there's things called medication
there's there's things you can do like
you don't have to suffer like this but
my handbook which I was playing from was
you have to be effed up to be an artist
you to the best
for for legacy for Transcendent if you
want to be known you have to be the most
messed up you have to you can't nothing
no great art I mean maybe great art but
that kind of transcendent art that
really touches people for for
Generations you have to you have to sell
your soul to the devil like you have to
and and Shane is the vehicle for
greatness and I and I totally bought in
I was like there's no one I know that's
like well adjusted that has like a
wonderful life that is doing anything
that's like and that's just this and
today I know there is it's just I didn't
yeah I didn't believe it at the time so
I I believe that and anything that would
get anything like to go to therapy or to
start taking pills or or to start
talking about my pain would get in the
way of the art and the art is the most
important and at that time I considered
my podcast art my pain everything I did
I was like that's my art and it needs to
be pure and it can't be uh edited it can
never be edited if I if I mess up in a
painting and you have to see my mess up
if I say say something that I that
should be edited like I I it's just it
has everything has to be pure I have to
show you
uh because everything in the society is
lies and manipulation and the best
version of things and I want to show you
the the ugly the ugliness and
and uh
I I just
I I wanted
you know I I was too cowardly to
actually kill myself but I wanted to get
into some kind of
situation where you know someone would
murder me or something would happen
where I would die I had a I had a angina
attack in a casino when I was 35 so I
have that heart disease
um and and that was the best because
when I collapsed
I felt so much joy
I felt so much joy in the same way
in those sound garden days when I was
doing graffiti and like
I had nothing I was just a punk kid
writing my name David show on a wall and
all these people were like dude you
painted in the that gang territory
they're gonna come after you the police
are calling your house because you wrote
your name
that was the happiest I was because I
was like it's gonna end soon my opinion
is going to end right like relief from
this self-created prison where self-care
is at odds with what you're trying to
express which is greatness through your
art right it is an impossibility to be a
great artist and to be well right and
and the pain of walking around being
like I'm not entitled to actually take
care of myself because that will
threaten the very thing that I care
about the most and I think
one of the most
um kind of interesting and impressive
things about this this you know growth
trajectory that you've been on is is
this chapter of of that that is perhaps
the most courageous like can you be
a great artist
as a happy well-adjusted grateful
grounded human being well is that not
like the ultimate challenge for us an
artist who's convinced that that you
know the expression is only a function
of how much pain you're in well let me
ask you this have in your adult working
life have you ever taken a year off no
I mean um not to get into your finances
have you made enough where you could
take a year off no
six months maybe maybe yeah so I got a
bunch of kids let's go with six months
so
um
when that was recommended to me
it was the same thing as me asking Stevo
to do a stunt and not film it or rain to
do a performance and not have anyone see
it it was like
that you're taking away my identity my
identity is working everything is for
work for
approval relevance
what happens if I stop yeah I can
disappear and I don't mean anything yeah
exactly and and who am I actually and so
someone even called me out on the thing
you just said they were like
you know for someone who's rebelled
against everything their whole life
you're pretty
[Music]
um
you're pretty close-minded and you're
pretty like cowardly about this creating
art from a positive place
because you have all these examples to
support your argument of how it you know
look at this guy look at look at how
messed up Picasso is and look at how you
know
and um
so you have so many examples to support
the messed up artist you know thing but
why can't you be the first right if you
can't think of any examples of someone
who's well adjusted has a loving life
and also a an amazing artist why don't
you be the first why don't you try it
and isn't that not the most punk rock
thing ever but it doesn't feel like it
because there's so little examples of
that so first thing was you need to take
a year off
and and I was at a place with a lot of
people and I was like
how come you're not asking that guy he's
like because he's not rich yeah he's
like you can if if everyone here can
afford it I would tell everyone here to
do it
so
this guy says
you're so close to death
and you may or may not know it but
because you can financially afford it
I'm asking you to take one year off
because your brain is on fire
like you can't sit like
right oh TV show the movies work on this
and then I'm gonna do this and then I'm
gonna put this like and you have so many
people calling you like a genius oh this
guy did this and he combined this and
and you're you're getting um all this uh
praise you know people are offering you
TV shows and
and and and that that that couldn't have
been the
that was the most offensive thing you
could say to me is to take a year off I
told the guy go [ __ ] yourself you know
he he um he's like and then he started
crying and I I I I hadn't experienced
that kind of level of vulnerability
before like with a man like he I was
ready to mix it up he tells me this I go
back and we're going to argue and I and
he goes hey you know just from meeting
you and how I feel of how you're coming
off right now and because you can
financially afford it I'm going to ask
you to take a year off and
I said go [ __ ] yourself and then he
started crying and I who is this guy
therapist uh his name is Patrick Carnes
and he is the known as like the
The Godfather of sex addiction you know
and um you know
uh just just for my background I have no
chemical addictions and every
um so interesting it's like the inverse
of me like I'm all about substances and
uh and and that's never been your thing
but what you know the gambling thing
came in a lot earlier in your life than
I than I realized well um
you know when people say OCD right they
think the a lot of hand washing or when
I walk I have to step on a certain you
know and I was like that as a young
child like when I walked to school I had
to step on the line of the sidewalk
squares like I couldn't stand on the
Square part and then if I missed one I
had to go back and do it you know like I
did I had that and then I was like oh I
haven't had weird Hang-Ups like that in
years and my therapist pointed out
you have the most severe case of ocdm
and I'm like what are you talking about
I don't have they go
so for me
and all the stuff that I've learned is
it helps right it helps for you to go
I'm an alcoholic right but is that
that helps with that because you need to
stop that behavior in that moment but
you know as you know things if you don't
get to the core and cut it out then um
it's whack-a-mole right it jumps so then
you become a drug addict and you stop
that then you become a sex and love
addict then you stop that then you
become a workaholic and a lot of these
things can cross over and so for me I
was a thief
from the from the from the time I can
remember
um my brother showed me how to shoplift
when I was uh six or seven
I remember Star Wars figures were 99
Cents at the time and I remember uh
another instance of how I'm not enough
um our allowance was uh you know 50
cents so I worked two weeks so I could
buy this
um Star Wars figure from the drugstore
and then I go I have a dollar you know
so I put the thing on and the tax comes
out 107 or something and I put the money
out and she's like you don't have enough
I go that thing's 99 Cents and she's
like there's a thing called taxing I'm
I'm a little kid going wait so I can't
have that and she's like no you can't
have it
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I just worked two
weeks for that and they're like yeah you
need like 10 more cents and I was like
holy [ __ ] and then we walk out of the
store and my brother's like I got it and
I'm like well you you work you get 50
cents too where did you get the extra 10
cents he's like oh I just I pulled it
out of the thing
so I was like you don't have to pay for
things and he's like no you just steal
you just take whatever you want
and I was like whoa it's such a and then
of course I grew up in a super religious
family where there's these um
sayings framed all over my house do not
steal you know and I was like of course
I gotta steal now you know yeah
so I stole every single day of my life
um from age eight till I was like
probably in my early 20s every day every
single day and and sometimes and it was
I didn't need to steal right like some
other stuff
and also your kleptomaniac and in my
mind I would steal a lot of food and
give it to homeless people I had a um
no one wants to think of themselves as a
bad guy right so I would steal like some
art supplies that I needed and I'm like
oh I'm a thief that's horrible I don't
wanna so I have to correct that I'm
gonna go out and steal from a
corporation and give to the poor so I
knew where all the wholeness people in
my neighborhood lived and I would go
steal food and and um it took years like
that's once again there's a story I'm a
hero yeah I steal from rich people and I
give to poor people I'm a good guy you
know and people be like you're a thief
you're a thief you steal that's not good
and I'd be like how does that relate to
OCD though because I have to steal every
day oh I see like every single day of it
like there and then and that also what
would happen if you went a day without
stealing
this is so it was a combination of Steel
and break the law
so my go-to was if I was laying in bed
and I was like
you know it was like anything from like
stealing a kid's homework so to copy off
of or like any kind of like deviant
Behavior
um I would this is crazy I would have to
climb out of my window I had to break
out of my own house hop the fence and go
across the street and jaywalk and then
go back inside my house just to be like
I broke a J-1 you know it had to be some
kind of thing like that and then
um
uh
I you know I got caught a bunch of times
I went to jail a bunch of times and then
I just decided one day hey like my mind
is so strong I'm just gonna stop cold
turkey
and which I did I've never stolen again
since the day I decided I'm I'm not
going to steal again but then the
gambling went up right and at that time
it's squeezing the water balloon yeah
and my friend uh Joey who he was the
first one of my friends who had um a
driver's permit
he got his driver's permit he drove to
Vegas by himself and he came back and he
said um
you know there's a place in the desert
and they play games of chance and when
you win they let you keep the money and
I was like let's go you know and you're
like 15. I was 15 and we had a fake ID
from uh Alvaro Street in in downtown and
you know so we you know we're going to
Vegas with like 20 bucks 15 and like
winning 40 bucks or six and we were
hooked
and it wasn't until years later that I
realized
um
both of my family but my mom and my dad
are gambling addicts um I don't know if
my dad's necessarily A gambling addict
but my mom definitely is my dad when we
were growing up um we didn't have a lot
of money so
um he would go to Vegas every weekend
and try to win rent money or whatever
and and because I know my dad he's not
like a
he's a very conservative like chill guy
he's not the guy that's like all in yeah
so I already know that kind of gambling
and like it's like a
you got to kind of be bold to to win
right but you are actually pretty
successful oh I was I was very
successful I'd I'd hacked the way to do
that and so
um as a Fu to my dad I had to you know I
made a lot more money gambling than I
did in art in the beginning you know so
yeah because I thought that the gambling
stuff happened kind of kicked in after
the whole Facebook thing but it really
was before I mean what was it full force
before all of that
well to put it in the context and you
know I know this story's been written
about a lot but
um
yeah what are some of the homeless
artists gets lucky when he you know
um and just to frame uh that that era
everyone was on Myspace
all right like everyone was like
Facebook was like this it wasn't a joke
but it was like this Niche social media
for college students
so
um and and Sean Parker the Napster guy
yeah Sean Parker like I I had met him uh
right after the Napster thing when they
were trying to get sued for a trillion
dollars and um he just was a fan of my
art and at that point my art was
starting you know it wasn't selling for
you know hundreds of thousands or
Millions but it was like I was a
painting that had used to sell for a 300
I was starting to sell for like two or
three thousand you know so my star was
starting to rise
and um he wanted to get some artwork but
because he's this kid that was you know
facing like
I don't know who's trying to assume like
all the record labels Metallica whoever
he's like um you know he and he's a very
confident determined he's like I will
get your art someday Dave Cho and I was
like cool come up with some scratching
you know so then he started another
company plaxo I don't know how it did
and then finally when it came to
Facebook he explained this thing to me
during the era of Myspace and I'm like
this sounds horrible the name sounds
horrible the logo is horrible I'm like
can I redo the logo like he's just like
this thing's gonna take over the world
and I'm like how how is it College
social network you know and and so I had
just gone out of prison in Japan and I
owed everyone money
and um you like punched a guy at your
show or something yeah I punched under
you know that's a whole other story I
can get into but I I needed a lot of
money
fast and so it was a blessing that he
was like hey Dave Cho
I told you one day I'm gonna get a pain
from you we got funding from
um Peter at PayPal like
and I said okay so he's like so what are
you charging now and I'm like what do
you want me to paint he's like I want
you to paint a mural on every single
floor and I was like you know I had
never gotten a job like that but I'm
like okay a painting one painting of
mine selling for like five grand now
that's like multiple so I said 60 Grand
and and if he said yes because I know no
one had ever paid me 60 Grand before you
know it's a lot of money it's a lot of
money now right
and he's like okay like he didn't even
he's like all right cool we can get you
that and I was like
holy [ __ ] I'm gonna be able to pay
everyone back I'm gonna and because I'm
a gambler he goes or
you could take stock
and
that's people like oh he's so lucky but
it's because I was a degenerate the
appropriate at the time the right thing
that was a crazy bet the right thing to
do yeah yeah the the the right thing to
do would have been to take the money pay
back my girlfriend at the time all my
friends who paid for my lawyer in Japan
paid all my back rent like that's the
right thing to do and so they're like I
remember my friends going Facebook
like dude go back get your money you
know
um but that's because I was a degenerate
Gambler I would take my Toys R Us you
know paycheck and go to Vegas and lose
it all and and
um
I was like there's there's gotta be a
way to win at this there's got to be a
way because everyone who gambles has the
same story
I was winning
right so there's always that part where
they were winning and then um
and then I lost it all and I go well how
can we change the story where it was
like I was winning period you know
and I was like oh it's a vice
it's like an addiction it's like it's
like when I hear an alcoholic say two
beers and I was good I was the life of
the party I was buzzing I was having a
good time
so why don't you stop there well because
I'm an addict then you have another one
then you're wasted so
um
all of these things is just like how can
I win at life
how can I win at life How can I
how can I feel good through all these
things that are supposed to make you
feel good
and then stop
and I go oh
I have no self-control
I have no self I can't stop myself
but someone else can
but that's not realistic if I was an
alcoholic is that realistic for me to go
to a bar and pay someone to drink with
me and on my third beer when I get me
off to but like literally like slap the
beer out of my hand
like is that really gonna happen
and I go well just because it hasn't
happened doesn't mean it can't happen
so I I paid my friend Harry Kim to come
with me to Vegas for seven years and
every time I was winning he would
physically take the money put it in his
pocket go upstairs and lock it up and
made sure I you know and I was like but
we were on a winning streak like we
could win more and he's like we're done
and sometimes he would have to
physically drag me away from the table
and the Pit Bosses and and all the
people that worked at the casino were
like we've never seen anything like this
before
we've never seen someone pay someone to
stop someone and I go well and you know
and all I have is that like technically
cheating do they end up cutting you off
yeah because you have a system they cut
me off at two casinos and then
ultimately when
my first
um GA meeting Gamblers Anonymous meeting
I ever went to
um and I got I got sober from gambling
in Hawaii which I chose Hawaii for my
rehab because there's that's the only
state in in America that where there's
no casinos
so there was no GA meetings there and
they said you should go to AAA meetings
I go well I'm not alcoholic and they go
well you go to the AAA meeting and um
whenever they say a drink or alcohol
just replace it with casino gambling you
know
but you can't share at those meetings
you know
because you can only share for that
particular thing and as someone who
likes to talk a lot
um that was really humbling to go to
three 400 plus AAA meetings that never
share once and just hear everyone else's
story
um and everyone's going who's that guy
never shares I've got some Darkness
exactly the flip side of the the
gambling addict thing is you know yeah
you set up this control but part of the
compulsion is that attachment to
[Music]
um
to also losing like the anticipation
well here here I'll I'll sum it up for
you so
I've been to every type of 12-step
meeting and the ones like because I'll
be in a city where oh [ __ ] I can't find
a gambler's Overeaters or or sex and
love addict or whatever the addiction
codependence I have yeah on a bottom
Carter and Fight Club exactly important
yeah and they're like oh there's only an
a meeting or Narcotics Anonymous or
marijuana anonymous so I'll go to that
meeting even though that's not my
addiction and as I listen to thousands
of people share their story
I go oh it's all gambling every
addiction is gambling addiction
every single when you drink and you get
in a car you're like I kind of don't
care if I make it home or not right
that's gambling when you're like having
sex and you're like I'm not gonna wear a
condom and you're like oh I might have a
kid I might get AIDS I might that's
gambling and and so
to go to my first Gamblers Anonymous
meeting after going to 400 AAA meetings
in Los Angeles
I was I was shocked because
AAA meetings and and Drug
um n a meetings are kind of like parties
in L.A right like it's very social
they're bright lights especially in L.A
300 people two you know their celebrity
speaker you know it's when you go to uh
a sex addicts meeting a gambler's addict
meeting uh you know the process ones
there's more shame yeah so the lights
are a little lower and dark there's a
yeah it's darker there's a lot of shares
that end with suicide attempts you know
so I went to a ga meeting and we went in
a circle in every single share it was a
small meeting it was like six people
um every single person shared about how
they try to kill themselves and I've
said this before it's the reason why
they don't have balconies in Vegas
because if they did there'd be someone
jumping off every day one out of four
gambling addicts kills themselves
um so people go gambling I don't
understand it's like
so I'm sitting at the meeting and
everyone's like telling how much money
they've stolen from their family or lied
and manipulated people out of so that
they could keep gambling getting that
once Lotto scratcher horse rate
everything right
and I'm scared to share because it's
going around the circle and it gets to
me and I'm like I just won three million
dollars at the my last you know that's
so crazy and I feel exactly the same as
you you just said you broke into a
course to steal a quarter so you can get
the next scratcher I'm sitting here
telling you I have two rotting lobsters
in my in my hotel room I'm having sex
with all these prostitutes and gambling
with millions of dollars winning handing
like hundred dollar bills to everyone I
know and I feel exactly the same as you
so I sat there and
I go
how do I feel how did I feel when I won
three million dollars at the on my last
trip all right and I'm playing a quarter
million dollar hands of blackjack in
private private rooms you know
and at that point I felt very little you
know but like you win three million
dollars it feels good
but not that good because I was already
rich
when I lose three million dollars and
even better yet when I lose 30 million
then that feels amazing right that feels
amazing so I think that was the
disconnect with
trying to talk to people in My Tribe who
are addicts and people who aren't
addicts right and it doesn't matter if
you're an addict or you're not an addict
because everyone knows an addict or at
least has one in their family so that's
the thing when people go I don't but I
don't understand why don't you stop
drinking or why don't you stop why don't
you stop the behavior it's like I want
to [ __ ] lose that's why do you get it
do you understand now I don't want to
win I'm happier when I'm losing I want
to lose everything but that's even
harder for somebody to understand
because you're not operating on a
rational plane right you know you're
trying to uh you know numb the
discomfort of your internal pain while
also seeking to feel something that will
make you feel alive and if winning's not
going to do it losing certainly is going
to to happen it doesn't matter what that
feeling is as long as it's a feeling
different from however you feel right
and so
sorry I got fired up there for a second
so that's hard to explain that's hard to
understand like wait
you know you're trying to wrap your
non-atic brain around someone who's
doing everything they can to
run away from everything feel numb feel
nothing feel everything
and so
everything was off you know I did I did
like these expensive brain scans to show
that I had like frontal like like a kind
of um temporary brain damage from just
like complete over stimulation like yeah
your dopamine must have been completely
[ __ ] up
and so
doctor's orders take a year off and I
had to sit in that and it's like well
um when was that this was uh
seven years ago so is this like the the
bottom
I'd never hit a bottom
um
which
you know when I asked you about the
podcast and you're like it's good and it
and and there's the the negative so one
of the things that I've I taught myself
into being a successful Gambler was
it's the Golden Rule get out while
you're ahead right it's like how do you
win at life get out what it's like
I look at a guy like Conor McGregor like
just loved and you know just dude if he
had just stopped like three four fights
ago he would just be a legend forever
and now he's starting to turn into the
villain and like [ __ ] if he just got out
while he's ahead and I think of you know
a lot of people like that but you get
addicted to the attention or what you
know whatever the thing is if you don't
and if you don't you know die at 27
right become that like glorified right
and that's what I was playing for I was
trying to die I was like once I hit 30 I
was like [ __ ] it was supposed to happen
before that now I'm 45. so
um the positives if I'm looking at the
bright side of gambling it had taught me
I had taught myself through discipline
and hard work how to get out while I was
ahead
so
um she's a very non-addict thing oh
right and and I and I was like man I've
been to jail
um
multiple times I've lost
um you know small fortunes I've you know
I had this like I've always had this
like kind of
no matter how much I try to hurt myself
there was
this is what it was
um
I've always uh [ __ ] I might start crying
talking about it but um I've always my
entire life
have valued
um
[Music]
um
friends over everything right
so I've learned a lot now I have a lot
of tools I've learned a lot of things in
recovery but I have
I have like the same friends that I've
met when I was in third grade you know
since I was eight years old and
I would do anything for my friends and
and I know that they feel the same
so I knew like girlfriends would come
and go I knew things but I I was like
what is the one thing that I must
because you hear stories you're like oh
yeah we used to be friends in college
and you know life happens and then you
grow and I was like no
like things come and go the one thing
that has to like stay constant in my
life is friendship so I nurtured those
things I nurtured I made sure no matter
what happened in my life I would take
trips I would call and and
when we say love we usually tend to
refer to romantic relationships but for
me I was like love
is for me like man love me loving
another man telling you know calling a
guy to tell him how much I love him
and so
that if I didn't have that I would be
dead right now if I didn't I can tell
you three stories right now where if I
didn't have a guy in my life that was
like we're not doing this Dave like I
would I would be dead right now so
that's the one and even in all the
recovery places people were like holy
[ __ ] dude you're getting a letter every
day from someone like you have we have
more friends than anyone and I said that
without that and I know that's not
um in the 12 steps or certain things but
like the most one of the most important
things for for my life and my recovery
is
these friendships are invaluable so you
know yeah
um I think that kept you alive it's like
have you read uh Johann hari's book lost
connection oh yeah that's about that
right so
so while you're while you're out there
like freewheeling and and getting like
crazier than anyone can imagine you have
all these friends who are trying to you
know get your attention and you know as
any good addict will tell you like you
just can't hear it like until you're
ready so even though you say you didn't
have a bottom you did reach a point
where you were receptive to some level
of self-care or friends we're trying to
tell you fairly receptive but but enough
to save your life right I had you know
my therapist like to say hope is not a
plan and I have
um people don't tend to think of me as a
guy who's like very calculated or has
plans but I had planned my bottom you
know I knew how much money I had in my
bank account I knew I knew you know my
brain like in the same way I pull off
this exit here my brain instantly knows
which fast food places I'm gonna eat at
after this interview I I know so in my
mind whether I wrote it out or not like
it had a plan of like and then you'll
lose this then you'll go on this bender
and then this and then you may die from
this thing but if you live then you do
this this and this and so in my brain I
always knew that there's treatment
centers I knew that there's hospitals I
knew that there's pills I could take I
knew there's people I could talk to but
it was like um
not yet
a little bit further to go right and the
ultimate but when someone's like I hit a
bottom there's always a further bottom
until it's yeah right death is the final
bottom so I was like I'm
I'm 25 away from the bottom that I would
like clean up my life you know and I
actually
hear this a lot from young young men I
talk to a lot of young men in their 20s
and they're like man you've done so much
[ __ ] up [ __ ] Dave like I feel like
almost like I need to do a little bit
more before I get help and uh and uh
deceptive side of
of addiction is if you tell someone you
have a problem with fentanyl or alcohol
they go oh you got a real problem you
better take care of that
but it's you know it's completely
acceptable today in our society uh for a
young person to wake up
gamify their love life right swiping uh
and then play video games for multiple
hours
uh masturbate to porn smoke the most
powerful weed and that's just
that's not a problem that's just life
everyone does that yeah that's the way
and and if I
if if I go to my manager and he opens up
my Instagram and he shows my DMs it's
just I'm lost I'm lost want to kill
myself give me give me um you know uh
you know some some things I can do you
know and it's just
so
I sat there in the same way I was like
what really is my problem
I wish I had a sex addiction you know I
was I was sleeping with multiple uh
women a day and not enjoying any of it I
was winning millions of dollars a day
and not enjoying any of it oh boo boo
Dave boo
and I go but it's a problem for me
it's a problem for me but if it becomes
an impediment to reaching out for help
because that's like who's gonna you know
yeah and that's why that and people
always go well we don't understand why a
guy like Bourdain killed himself and I
go that's why right because everyone's
he's already a God and everyone
considers him the most interesting man
in the world is that guy allowed to come
to you and say
yo I'm like you and I and well dude come
on man you got you know yeah so that's
where I was at yeah I I had I was hiding
in plain sight in all these social
acceptable having too much sex gambling
and like just man you have you go to uh
you know fly to Vegas in a private jet
and a Bentley picks you up and you know
and I
I I was just I was dying inside but you
did have that group of friends who knew
that it was out of control and were
trying to help you so you know had you
had raised your hand earlier that that
peer group who I mean didn't they
intervene on you a bunch of times I mean
you know they were trying to they was
doing intervention
there was another intervention in the
rehab to stand to stay like I try to get
out how many rehabs did you go to
um I've been to well I don't know if
rehab's the right words I've been to
centers I've been to The Meadows I've
been to Pine Grove uh Salon Hoffman PCH
um I I mean I can't yeah some of those
are more behavioral yeah yeah a lot of
it's behavioral stuff so
um you know
yeah the last one they physically you
know and and that and that kind of
you know when you pick a sponsor and
stuff you're like do I want a sponsor
who's going to be like nice to me and
and be gentle or do I want hey like
drill sergeant so I I you know
today I need more gentleness but I was
at the time in my life where I wouldn't
because of how I was raised I really
wouldn't respond to people unless they
were yelling at me or physically
um so that's what I needed at the time
and in my mind I was like [ __ ] there was
am I am
and my friend one of my closest friends
he said to me in the car ride he said
Hey listen um
like
we can't change you we can't control you
so if you want to get out of the car
right now go ahead
um but you're not an idiot you know how
this story ends you've seen enough
you've watched enough movies you know
enough people like you will die you will
go to jail again you like these things
will happen so the only thing you got a
question is do you want to do it now or
do you want to wait till you hit your
bottom and I was like I kind of want to
wait till I hit that bottom and um
in that moment of sobriety and Clarity I
was like I'll get the help now and then
I went to the my first place and I met
people
who it was like
it was just like shocking you know just
people you know as as an addict
these are these are those things like
when you're growing up in in your
innocent and you're a kid
and when I when I look at children and
they're just they're just pure
and you tell yourself
you know whether you just start casually
drinking or casually looking at porn or
casually smoking marijuana you go well
I'll never I'll never suck a dick for a
crack on Skid Row yeah it's never it's
not the plan for anybody but then it
happens
so I think of how many things in my life
I said I'll never do that and yet here I
am doing these things and then
um the addict craves novelty right so
you play the thing out until it you
don't feel anymore and then you're like
what's behind door number two and or you
know and then the final door is death so
um I got to meet the people
who took it to the furthest and I was
like holy [ __ ] I'm so glad I pulled the
parachute when I did you know
and um
and and and today I mean
you know I have a lot of I am a sponsor
to a lot of people in different programs
and I have a lot of Shame
um that I've never gotten anyone past
step two in the 12 Steps because
uh you know I take people through the
way my sponsor took me through and one
of the things is
I've yet to meet
um
someone with the Iron Will a
well-disciplined brain who can resist
the Temptations of a cell phone right
because what is a cell phone is a drug
dealer strip club casino like I could
tell you a million stories of
how I used to get high off those things
and what I had to do to get porn when I
was 15 what I had to do to get to a
casino now it's just this right so I'm
not going to be able to resist that
so what's the first thing anyone says
when they say we need to take your phone
away or we need to block your phone so
that you have a child safe phone oh I
need it for work right oh it's for work
okay right then it's okay and they go
well
can you have someone else do the work
stuff for you oh no no I gotta do it
myself
so until I was ready to fully surrender
which took years
um and now and now it's I'm so liberated
right you would think oh
why do you need to restrict me and oh
like the news and [ __ ] like you you got
to be informed I was like I know what's
going on I don't know if people have
phones they tell me what's going on she
literally don't have a phone haven't had
one I have a phone but it's it has um
all the apps or whatever there's two
main apps it's called Moby Sip and
Covenant eyes there there might be a
better one now but those
my phone is I can only use it to take
pictures and to call people or text
that's it right so I can't like look at
the internet and I can't you know so how
long have you been doing that five years
now yeah yeah and it changed my life I
mean it it has to just make you a
happier person oh my God it's like
it's
you know one of the luxuries I spend a
lot of time and and I'm sad that I
haven't been able to since covid in
Tanzania with this tribe the hadza their
hunter-gatherer yeah I remember you
talking about that on Rogan so
I mean when you wake up in in your day
and
what are the things that we say here in
our sins I need a job I'm looking for a
job or you know what should I do today
like when you're when you're
hunter-gatherer you have a job it's get
food that's it every day every day when
you wake up it's get food and there's no
free time so when I come home in the in
the anxiety and the stress and all these
things start to build even without a
phone just living in a city
because the city isn't a natural kind of
thing
that free time that freedom of like
having free time is is the thing that
you know
if if I'm if I have free time I will get
into trouble right uh Idle Hands Are The
Devil's Playground all that stuff like I
will get into some some stuff so
um to have to wake up and just have
purpose you know so one of the things is
restricting the phone so that I don't
even have I don't I don't know what I
don't know it's just and then having
things uh in my life uh that are
meaningful and you know
one of the hardest things was
doing that surrendering the phone and
then
the second thing was lying which
um comes in many different forms right
like you're a liar everyone listening to
this thing is a liar
no I'm not I'm not a liar and I go well
there's Lying by withholding information
there's lying through storytelling
changing details exaggeration
and there's you know using that's not
lying but like using humor to like you
know deflect deflect there's all these
things so
um
I it took me forever to just admit that
I was a liar you know I was at a place
that was pretty severe they put you on a
lie detector every week and they ask you
questions and
and you know my thing to rewire your
brain rewire your brain I go this isn't
normal like No One's Gonna put me in a
lie detector in real life they go we
know that but while you're here and
you're getting help we want you to
and I go but that's
people know me as a Storyteller if I
don't exaggerate and like you know come
up with funny anecdotes and like then
then who am I
and they go that's fine there's a
there's a time and place for that and my
brain is so binary with like I'm either
this guy or this you can't you know and
they're like you can you can there's a
time and place for things and it just it
just took forever where
the place where I was at was so serious
and so depressing and so much trauma and
addiction and all these things that I
was the class clown right every meeting
would end with me going uh like turning
a joke into everything so on one leg
they put a sticker that said no joking
and then on the other leg it said no
lying so um yeah all your tools all my
tools and and they said look we're we're
not they're like we're not your friend
we're your treatment team like
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want when
you get out of here but we're not
judging you yeah you lying you where did
you learn how to lie from your parents
from the way you grew up you grew up in
a very unsafe environment so you had to
train yourself to lie
so that you could be safe so for that
you could be grateful but guess what
you're not a kid anymore you don't ever
need to lie again ever
because it's so ingrained into how you
speak sometimes you just do it without
so I go well what do I do in that
situation they go well you can correct
yourself within 24 hours and I go what
so when you lie and you catch yourself
and you tell a story that you've told a
million times and then you're like wait
a second that actually isn't true
and that was like
I mean that's through my friends they
were like what the [ __ ] who are you I
might say something and they would be
like hey you run today and I'm like yeah
I did I did a quick hike and then the
next time and then I'd call them an hour
later and go hey you know you know what
I said I did a hike I actually just went
outside to cut the newspaper and one of
those things was this story that you you
told repeatedly around like the
television show thing right right right
um
see I'm even trying to go like which
what's the line what's the truth um
um I had I had just done Howard Stern
and Scott Rudin had heard the interview
and he said I don't understand how no
one's optioned your life for a TV show
yet and um so I do some quick research
who's Scott rooting I'm like oh [ __ ]
he's like he got he's the he's done
everything you know he's done um you
know he's done every single TV show that
I watch and every movie that I like and
he's like what if if I was to turn your
life into a TV show what would what
would you how do you see that I'm like
has to be irreverent has to be
ridiculous it has to be like Curb Your
Enthusiasm has to be the most ridiculous
version of me and use me at at my
expense like humiliate the [ __ ] out of
me like the more you make me look like a
loser and stuff the better and he's like
I got the perfect guy for you and so
um this was the rehab I was in Hawaii
um for gambling addiction or that's what
they told me on the phone and I got
there and they'd never heard of it so I
was at this rehab where everyone was
there for meth and I was there going
uh so they you know this was probably
not appropriate but a weekend I'd barely
just gone in they sent um
Harris whittles who had written for
parks and rec and Eastbound and Down
to to interview me and he um
he was interviewing me and and you know
there's
I don't know like 100 hours of tape of
me telling him all my childhood stories
and all the crazy stuff I did
and so that was one one deal
and then the other deal was um
Bourdain had been and grooming me to you
know he wanted me to write a book for
him on his publishing label and
he you know his his team were like you
know he's not going to do this forever
right so you know he's he's he wants to
pass the mantle at some point
you know like holy [ __ ] he goes the
thing with you and Tony is you know I
have a show on I had a show on Vice
called thumbs up where I hitchhike
around the world right and um you know I
don't know a couple people saw that but
you know and he has like the biggest
show and and um but he goes but for you
to travel and talk to people that's just
your life it's not like you would have
to like do that you know so you your
your life is very similar to his and
instead of the food angle you could do
like an art angle
and I was just like
so sick in all of my addictions and I'm
like and yet
once again I'm being rewarded I'm
getting these TV show deals and and that
wasn't the LIE those things were true
but then I said something on my podcast
that got me canceled and all those deals
disappeared and because I couldn't live
with um you know abandonment and
rejection is one of my biggest traumas
you don't [ __ ] say no to me I say no
to you and as long as I'm talking on the
mic edit remix like oh I turned those
offers yeah yeah the story that you told
us that you walked away from that
because you had this self-awareness that
you didn't want to have a life that was
like Tony's that made it very difficult
for him to be in public and you're like
I have enough money like I don't really
want that piece of Fame so I don't know
which made you sound
like courageous and heroic and actually
you know so that it's not so binary
there was truth in that like but that
option was just taken away yeah like as
I was contemplating do I want a TV show
is this what I want it was like record
scratch it's off the table and I was
like okay I guess it doesn't really
matter meanwhile Harris overdoses and
dies from
yeah
so I knew I knew him a little bit not
well but
yeah I mean I
[Applause]
I he he died
um while I was in at The Meadows and um
you know he had just gone sober so he
texted me and um one of the reasons why
that show didn't move forward was
the script that he turned in was
horrible and I was so codependent with
him at that point I didn't know how to I
was like this guy's one of my favorite
writers and
uh and he had told me he had started
taking
um you know Oxycontin once one a night
and um
and and I didn't know what that was
until I learned at this place that was
supposed to be for gambling that that's
like basically heroin and I was like
well you you better be careful man he's
like I got it Dave I'm all right
so
um
looking back I'm like man he asked a lot
of like recovery questions when he came
to interview me and I was like oh maybe
he was like trying to get help for
himself you know
and so when I was at my second rehab at
The Meadows
he had um
he had died but the last text he sent me
was hey Dave
I'm so sorry about that script I sent
like a year ago it was I don't know if
you know but I was like so messed up on
drugs it was like the worst thing I've
ever written I owe you a a new script
um and uh
and I'll see you when I when you get out
of this place like try not to have sex
with any of the nurses or you know
something like that something like
Harris and then like um two weeks later
I found out that he had passed and
um
that was my perfect excuse to get out of
rehab I was like my friend's dead I
gotta go to his funeral and they're like
you just got into treatment like a real
place not like the place that says there
for gambling you know
do you think your friend who's dead now
would want that for you and I was like
[ __ ] you for saying that like [ __ ] like
who the like he's my friend of course
I'm gonna go to his funeral and pay and
they're like your friend died in
addiction do you think he'd want you to
leave and I that just made me so angry
but everything made me angry right so
you weren't exactly in a place of
surrender right but I did I did I
surrendered and they said look
um we can have a memorial service like
in the desert you know you can pick a
place and you can honor him how you want
to honor him and so
um
I did that instead you know and it's
just
um I I've Just Seen
um
you know I I've I've just been to so
many of these places and they're so
expensive and if and I go to these AAA
meetings and they're free and I and I
sit here and
it's not me just rebelling just to Rebel
or or to challenge just a challenge but
it's like
whenever
Bill started AAA he's like okay that was
a different time right yeah
so
um and you know you've talked to so many
people and I've talked to so many people
and I sit here and I go a a Alcoholics
Anonymous
and yet
we all know addicts or we are addicts
ourselves
and so there's all this like isn't the
anonymity part of the shame right like
and I think to
um my days as a graffiti artist right
and I go to I was on on tour with um
this guy saber and retina and we go to a
strip club and the strippers have
Anonymous hi I'm Laser hi I'm like
everyone has superheroes super villain
names which is also derived out of Shame
right it's all shame maybe protecting
them also because it's dangerous to do
that right weird stalkers of course yeah
but but it is but now we live in a world
of only fans and and porn stars are more
accepted and sex workers are more
accepted and
and I've been to meetings where the most
powerful famous people on the planet are
there and yet it's and I go can we get
rid of I don't know if we're there yet
but can we get to a place closer where
where um we get rid of the anonymous
part yeah can we have this tricky right
It's Tricky I mean I've made personal
choices around my own anonymity or lack
thereof but I'm also cautious about
protecting other people's anonymity and
then the line gets really gray when it
comes to just talking about AAA
generally right on a public platform
because technically it violates one of
the Traditions so I never know where
that line is because my motivation is I
want to I want people to understand that
this is something that's available to
them I want to destigmatize it because I
had a lot of Shame about going into it
and I had a lot of assumptions and
judgments about what it was based on
what I saw on television or movies and
having no real connection to it or
knowing anybody that was in it because
it's anonymous
and yet there still is a lot of stigma
you know not everywhere is Los Angeles
so how do we that's true well we talk we
talk about it I think we we talk about
it but we're careful and conscious about
the way in which we talk about it
well part of the the 12 steps is is
um higher power right you know and so
for someone who grew up with spiritual
and religious abuse
that was the part where I was like I'll
just cut this part out I'll do 11 steps
you know or I'll do I'll do seven steps
I don't need these I was like trying to
edit pick and choose and um
you you bring up tradition right that
you know as as humans we like you know
we like a structure we like tradition we
like you know
and I just had so much trouble with that
part I'm like I grew up in a really
religious abusive house and I don't I
don't I don't pray to God I don't do any
of that stuff you know and they go well
you're gonna have a tough time because
you know the way they word it is like
the higher power of your understanding
right and I go I don't understand any
higher power
and then I finally had a sponsor that
said I don't care they're like you're
mortal right you're a human being I go
yeah
so your ego like what what part of you
thinks that you would ever understand
see or comprehend what God is
and I go so I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're like you know
so you go through all the religions all
the history of the world and you're like
my God is blue and has 20 arms mine has
a beard might you know
like didn't you say you're an artist I
go yeah I'm an artist
someone made that church
someone wrote that hymn someone designed
that you know flying buttress someone
made that that hat and like these are
humans like they might be touched by God
but someone made these things like
someone drew that portrait of Jesus
like you're very limiting when it comes
to like why don't you draw your own God
and I was like whoa that's a that's a
heavy homework assignment and he's like
you know until you until you do that
like I actually don't care I want you to
get on your hands and knees which is a
very humbling position like praying like
sitting up putting your hand like get
like begging position I need food I need
water like I please sir give me your
clothes like I want you to get in the
begging position and beg for your life
back every night that's how you pray and
so that's how I that's how I got in
touch with my higher power and then
today I you know
um not trying to use my head too much
but just more my heart like
you know people like to talk about you
know I'm in the flow or some you know
something like that like in my mind and
I go
creativity is God like us as humans what
differentiates us from other animals and
I go when I'm creating that's me praying
when someone's like sitting and like
life is boring I'm in a prison cell or
I'm at home and life is no meaning and
it's just like wait I got an idea for a
song or I want to try to make a new kind
of silverware eating utensil I got a new
idea like I'm like that is that is
conscious contact with a higher power
that is me directly God speaking to me
and me speaking to God and so
um
I don't know that's just the anti-social
side of me that's always questioning
okay so the 12 traditions are like we
have to be press and media how we talk
about this and that and I and I go
what did I learn in all the 12-step
meetings I've been to what did I learn
in all the behavioral places the Mental
Hospitals like I've been to so many and
it's like
did you have to be the most messed up
did you have to hit a bottom to go there
did you have to have an addiction to go
there and it's like no
I think about school and education what
did I learn
you know uh photosynthesis do I did I
need to know that did I need algebra all
these things I learned it's like did I
need to learn how to
speak up for myself ask for what my
needs are did I need someone to show me
what a boundary is and how to use it
like
I mean like I'll tell you something that
happened today that um like I was like I
was like gleaming on the car right here
it took me like an hour to get here and
I was just like overjoyed
um my mom's been doing this like kind of
massage thing to me since I was a kid
where it's a I guess it's Asian where
she just steps on my back and she's just
like all my pressure points
so she saw me and she's like you're fat
you look fat and disgusting I go thanks
Mom she goes your neck you know your
posture is horrible and and you know
I've put on a lot of weight during the
pandemic and she's like get down I'm
gonna I'm gonna massage you and um as
she's massaging me she starts talking
about
some Bible story and um
and one of the boundaries I've had in my
life is
I'm not telling you how to worship your
God just when you come into my home like
I would I would like it if you didn't do
that and so the child in me would would
be like Mom if you [ __ ] do that I'm
never gonna talk to you again it's very
childish immature and she already knows
I will talk to her again
so as they say boundaries without
consequences is just a request so she
starts doing that and then and then I'm
I'm I have what the therapist called uh
emotional incest with my mom like she
she's a meshed with me and mesh man so
another thing that she said
so as you know lower back
all you know Joseph in the Bible and the
Technicolor Dreamcoat and whatever and
I'm like
I go oh this is I have a voice I can say
hey mom I've asked you not to you know
but instead because she's literally
stepping on me and stepping on me like
verbally
um I didn't say anything so that she
gets higher she goes you know
it doesn't really matter who you you
choose to be with you know if who you
start a family with
they'll never be your mother and I go oh
great and she goes
and and then like so funny and she's
literally stepping on my head while
she's saying this and she goes like
physically repressing you yeah
physically repressed she's you know
laying down the emotional [ __ ] dead
weight
if
it's so funny and sad at the same time
because it's comical or it's it's driven
by her fear like she's afraid that she's
gonna lose you right and in that moment
I start I I can at this point I'm so in
tune with my body that I can go okay
time to send my mind somewhere else like
I'm gonna consciously disassociate
because I I don't and so I go part of my
self-defense mechanisms is humor so I
gotta turn this into a joke now and I go
so what so what mom like what do you
mean she's like well
you know if you get married and you
start a family like
say you kill someone and I'm like this
is ridiculous she goes say you murder
someone
your wife may or may not protect you
but me
you know I'm gonna hide you you know I'm
Gonna Get You just you know
and I just start I just start dying I
just start dying I'm like laughing and
I'm laughing because I want to cry you
know and she leaves you know she
finishes stepping on my head and my neck
and then she leaves
and uh asserting her dominance yeah
she's like I'm I'm the the main [ __ ] in
your life and just and and don't you
forget it you know
and she leaves and I sit there and I go
I feel horrible right now you know I
don't feel good and I start to think
um
you know I don't have Rich till like 11
I should go eat a cheeseburger at
McDonald's right now that'll make me
feel better
and I go oh how about I reinforce that
boundary
you know so I go I drive to her house
before I come here and I say
I open with gratitude and positivity I
go mom so not so it's not like a I don't
want it to be a shaming thing with her
and and I also don't want to go into
codependence where I'm like protecting
but you're a good mom you know
I say hey Mom I come here with love you
know that I love you you know how much
you mean to me uh and yet I've asked you
repeatedly not to
um and and this is what my therapist
taught me they're like if you're cutting
someone out of your life it's one and
done right you're like don't do this and
the next time you do it you're out but
if it's someone like a family member
that you want to keep in your life you
will have to train them like a dog like
the neuroplasticity stuff it's like it's
not like you're gonna hold the boundary
once and they're gonna learn you will
have to repeatedly do that so you're
gonna have these awkward uncomfortable
conversations but I'm at the point now
where I'm in seven years so I like
awkward uncomfortable conversations and
so I said hey um I've asked you not to
bring up you know the Jesus stuff and
I've asked you to not you know do this
stuff where you're you're you own me and
you're my property it's disrespectful to
the people in my life and it's not cool
and it doesn't make me feel good
she launches immediately like the
Playbook says into defense oh oh gas
lighting no no no you heard me wrong
that's not what I was saying maybe it's
because it's English let me say it in
Korean says the exact same thing and I
and I I find myself reverting to a 12
year old girl yeah
oh oh oh oh you're right you know you
know and I go
so I've heard everything you said and I
still love you and because you didn't
um you know
do what I asked when you come to my
house
uh to take because I love you but I also
love myself
uh I need a timeout from you and you
can't uh come into my house for the next
two weeks and
you know
um okay cool yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
cool and then um
you know on the way here uh
she texted me you're gonna like this
it's like a her [ __ ] you to me I'm
trying to be as functional in a
dysfunctional
uh the thing with that though is like
doing it from a place of neutrality
right you're not triggered and you're
not being reactive and you're also not
attached to whatever her reaction is or
is not right like she's gonna react
however she's going to react it's not
about changing her behavior it's about
releasing that boundary so that you're
free and you're not carrying around that
out that all that like baggage and shame
Rich I'm free man yeah like I what did
she say did you read oh you want to read
it yeah that's her it's her um I don't
know how how you want to take this but
uh
here it is
oops
okay hi with peace and love
uh I want to get some things off my
chest because it's important for me that
I am known and like that's also not how
she talks so someone's definitely
correcting
uh and I have a dog and like she's asked
me don't bring your dog in the house and
it's like a little dog that's not
annoying at all but because my mom has
her own trauma with like a dog biting
her when she was in Korea I do not want
dogs in my house I am uncomfortable and
I want this feeling to be respected this
is my house and I need to feel
comfortable
and about Meal Time
I work very hard on cooking good meals
for everyone I put a lot of love into it
please from now on make sure that
everyone waits for my prayer before we
eat please respect me thank you
[ __ ] hilarious for so many reasons
like we've spent an hour on that text
alone like on the one hand it's awesome
that she just completely deflected you
and didn't acknowledge anything about
what you said and just comes back with
her own boundaries which yeah on another
level like good for her yeah no like
she's got some pain around whatever
boundary you're just absolutely and
she's asserting that boundary so cool
and so like a dog it's funny that we're
talking about dogs
um
I all these behavioral places uh I'm
usually the youngest guy there like you
know when I was 35 like most of the guys
were in their 50s or 60s and we're
learning all these things about
neuroplasticity and how to change
behavior and I'm like these
[ __ ] aren't Gonna Change like
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
they're not going to change it's like
you have to do so much I do believe in
neuroplasticity but you have to do so
much work and focus and discipline for
it to work and um and I get out and I
tell my brothers this is all the [ __ ] I
learned and they're like don't you think
Mom's Gonna Change and to her to her
credit she has in the last five years as
I
like
to me the reason why I feel good is
um good for her for her boundaries
because she wouldn't have said it like
that I'm not sending you a reactive text
but like waiting a little bit having
somebody help her craft the language
exactly I mean this is thought into it
you know not to make it a race thing I
don't know any Asians that talk like
this like this is like advanced level
karate like I and and she did say she
did acknowledge me you know she I I said
my boundaries and I said for this reason
this is why you can't come over for two
weeks and then it's for me to just feel
safe in my own house like oh here she is
just creeping in again and uh she lives
five minutes from my house that's why
and so I you know and I
any other time in my life number one I
could never say that to my mom I'm your
[ __ ] mother you don't talk to me that
way if I'm crossing your boundaries good
you know how much [ __ ] I did for you you
know how much stuff I had to go through
to bring you here so I okay okay I'll
keep it down so not only would I not
bring it up
if I brought it up it would be so much
shame on like but you know but if you
don't want to you know like oh oh maybe
not two weeks maybe three days you know
like it would be a lot of backpedaling
apologizing gotta make sure she's okay
and all of it goes to she's my Elder
she's my mom I respect her you know
um and the the mortality of it how much
longer is she gonna live yeah 10 20 30
years I guess I'll just
you know at the cost of me I guess I'll
just keep myself down for the next 20 30
years and and to now to speak up it's
like
she's an adult she can take it and and
and so everyone in my family's noticed
they're like wow Mom has
changed in so it's just
is that addiction stuff it is because
all that
it's such a strange sentence to say out
loud
my mom said something about God to me I
didn't know how to feel about it so I
lost a million dollars at the casino and
had sex with prostitutes I didn't want
to that's my old it's like it's like
that's what happened my mom said
something to me so now I did something
so that my body would get hurt or
someone you know I went on a podcast and
said outrageous things about her so that
I would you know I would feel more shame
and people would hate me more or I could
end up canceling like that's how it
would manifest and and there was and
beneath it all is this child who is is
is deeply sensitive and and like
naturally very empathetic who who has
trouble processing all of the emotional
stimuli that the world is throwing at
him compensates for that through all
manner of behaviors and creating all
kinds of chaos only to return to this
place where he has to heal himself so
that he can Embrace his natural tendency
toward empathy and celebrate his
sensitivity
see immediately as I want to make a joke
right now but instead it's true like
when I like when you the the minute you
walked in here
you defied my expectation of how you
were going to comport yourself because
you were very calm and you were kind of
quiet and my relationship with you is is
seeing you know kind of a little bit of
the crazy
and then in watching your show which is
the whole reason that you know we came
together today like I see somebody who
like the whole motivation behind the
show it seems to me at least what I got
out of it is your ability to to
sit with people
in their pain
and and kind of
[Music]
um
celebrate our shared Brokenness as
something beautiful hmm
yeah I I appreciate you seeing all of
that I
so to go from the lies of the TV shows I
had to
I I have no desire to be on TV and yet I
am on TV right like there's no part of
me like you're a walking conundrum yeah
in that or like you're you know you're I
mean hypocritical I think is is cast
like a negative connotation on it but
you're you're you contradict yourself
and part of that is what it means to be
an artist I think at least in your case
it's so fun for me to have like
Bourdain's team call me or David Chang
or you know whoever and say hey can you
come on the show for you know I hop in I
hop out I have none of the pressure of
carrying the show it's fun for me
um my life is a life of service now
that's something I'm also work you know
I do
I can never say it's so difficult my
therapist said it's so easy for you to
to play the heel right that's that's how
you get high that's
um the more you play the heel the more
people talk about you the more attention
you get the more money you get the more
all this for you to go and say what you
really do with your life which is give
your time to helping people you know
donate to all these things anonymously
once again Anonymous I go well it's such
a douchey thing to be like I donate to
this and this and they go well
why not tell people what you do because
as someone who people some people do
look up to you and look to you as a role
model for you to say hey I you know on
The Joe Rogan thing talking about the
hanza
tons of people
uh donated money and and are helping
with the cause now and actually helping
those people and
and I go yeah I still feel weird because
it's like look at me I'm and I don't
want to be that guy that's like I donate
I'm the hero so I hide all the good
things I do because I don't want to
I don't know that there's some kind of
Shame with someone saying it's I feel
way more comfortable when people are
like
you know I look at some of the replies
uh of the show they're like oh the show
changed my life it's great and my friend
was gonna kill himself he watched the
show was great and I just go through
that and then there's one going you're
you're a fraud your show host is a p
it's the garbage like it's unwatchable
and I go oh here we go yeah now I like
this you know
so I
it goes back to everything I'm talking
about right now I go
I'll I'll spend the entire day with the
kid and he'll think nothing's wrong with
them but and yet he's suicidal and he's
I you know I can't it's not drugs it's
not alcohol but and yet I and so I'll
I'll give my life force and my energy to
this kid and at the end of the day I'm
like I'm so happy that I was able to
help one other person and then my ego
flares up and goes
[ __ ] if that day was filmed and it was
on TV then I could have helped hundreds
millions of you know whatever
and yet it's just to be like that was
enough I was enough that day and you
know and
so I always believe like and this is
something I'm working on but I I believe
100 that nobody believes in me you know
I've been in Pitch rooms I've pitched TV
shows before and you know the way those
two TV show deals got pulled out because
I said something on a podcast I go okay
so I don't and and we live in a
fear-based society fear-based religion
fear-based you know uh so I go okay the
only way for me and and the way I look
at the show show my TV show is is how
can I give back the things I've learned
um to the most amount of people
and I go is it on social media well
that's one component of it but you know
at this point I still don't know too
many kids that watch TV most kids I know
watch YouTube and tick tock
um but I go I think TV is still relevant
enough and um
and
um you know there's something going on
in
Topanga Malibu this area like you Rick
Rubin Neil Strauss like there's there's
like um
I get I get
I'll be honest like I feel more
comfortable now that now that we've sat
here for a little bit but like Neil
Strauss is a friend of mine he's
one of the smartest guys I know he's one
of my friends with Neil yeah he's one of
my favorite writers I know that you know
him and
I talked to him close to nine to 12
hours I I don't remember because it went
into the night and then the next day
when you oh you mean when you were
Taping that episode so he's actually in
the TV show for like I don't know five
minutes 10 minutes maybe uh or less but
that day I was so
intimidated in the same way when I was
coming here I'm like he's so smart he
has so much information in that brain he
talks so fast he's so witty he's so
clever
and so I just I'm like oh man I gotta
study I gotta you know I got you know
like in the same way
so many people in treatment
um you know the way when you see it
physically when someone physically
transforms their body into a bodybuilder
and they're like look at how strong I am
no one can ever hurt me you know my dad
beat me but no one ever is gonna I'm a
UFC Muscle Man fighter no one's ever
gonna fight me
um
so many of the people that I've met in
treatment are geniuses right they're
brilliant they're they have these
they've they've invented stuff they've
started entire economies so
their brains are they they and and as
the therapist says you're not gonna
outsmart outrun out an emotion no matter
what you know
you think of Facebook you're like wow
This brilliant guy
started a social media giant because he
wanted to have sex with women right and
you think of Elon Musk you're like this
guy is gonna get us to Mars because he
wants to run away from his dad
right like it's just
what are we gonna do when we get to Mars
we're gonna mess up Mars like why don't
you just go to therapy like and it's
like that fear he's like I'm less scared
of martians and Mars than what's what
I'm gonna find out here you know yeah
so I go and to be and to be living your
life
unconsciously reacting to that thing you
know right and just action after action
after action after action created life
around some wound Wounded Warriors man
my entire you think that you can just
push away I thought I'd deal with and
and that's why
I guarantee you that you can run longer
than me but if we went out in the
parking lot and did a 50 meter dash
I can beat you because I'm a sprinter
and I can I can run so fast and and you
know when I was doing thumbs up when I
was doing like when I was like yeah and
I'm a gambler and I'm people like what
are you running away from and it was
that unconscious like
I just can't sit still for one second if
I sit still for one second then
it's discomfort so even sitting with
Neil and then doing that talk
I know he had just started doing a
podcast of reopening murder trials and I
felt great fear for his child for his
wife
and I just sat in that I was like I'm
not going to outsmart Neil Strauss he's
smarter than me he's more brilliant than
me I just want to tell my friend how I
feel and he was talking circles around
me and trying to someone needs to do it
Dave like someone needs to like and I go
but
but why you and
and he
and so for hours just verbal sparring
and like and then finally after we
finish he got in the car he's driving
back to Malibu and I call him and
he's like I gotta apologize to you and I
was like what he's like
well you were just trying to tell me how
much you love me and how you're worried
about me and I just went into like
intellectualism and and I was like [ __ ]
I wish you could have said that on the
show and he's like well I I owe you
another better interview so he came back
and we talked for another six hours and
then he was way more vulnerable then and
I was like these are conversations I've
never seen in my life on television
and so
um
in my mind this is my life in my life I
get naked with other men I I share every
part of me and they share their and we
cry together and I do this with
everybody and so when people go oh
that's such a brave thing you did or
whatever it's just my Norm so when it
was time to put something like this on
television
people were you know there was a lot of
episodes that got pulled you know
there's in in the last seven years I've
interviewed over 2 000 people and no
one's a in the same way no one has ever
heard some of these podcasts and I have
thousands of paintings no one's ever
seen
um there's still fear in me I go I have
a lot to share and it's completely
unedited like it's just the whole
spectrum of human and everyone who cares
about me and is is saying don't put that
stuff out there and so I so I go you
know what uh one of the things that rich
people tell other rich people is don't
pay for your own stuff like why would
you pay you know you can get other
people to pay for it and I go well when
other people pay for it they get
creative control whatever so I made the
show exactly the way I wanted to
I talked to you know
all these people that I know or know of
and
and uh
it was
I don't know if television is the medium
for me because there is they call it uh
streaming Wars for a reason there's all
these analytics and stuff that people go
okay if you get Seth Rogen on your show
then you get more views and you know
like and I I'm just trying to
um
it's the question I asked you earlier
for me to do a show like that I I know
that I'm helping people and and I'm
helping myself
but what's the cost of that
right I don't know what is the cost of
it I mean my sense in watching it is
that it's very clear that it's this
heart-centered piece
it's so creatively unique in its
expression that it could only be you so
it's definitely
um you know this sense of like living in
your mind or or or or kind of living
inside of one of your paintings and it's
a reflection of all of this work that
you've done like is somebody you know
who's steeped in recovery and therapy
and the like like
those are conversations that I have that
I've learned to have that I look forward
to that I appreciate that are you know
so important in my life but I'm also
very aware that that's not the norm with
most people so how do you give people a
sense of of what that can be like for
them the healing power of that and the
beauty and and I think that you found a
way to do it in a really entertaining
and creative way leading with
vulnerability and guiding people who
perhaps have no uh you know prior
experience with anything like that to
show them not only like are these
conversations okay to have but just how
empowering they can be and when you hear
someone like you know Neil or Stevo or
or you know the other people that you've
had like share their pain and you
realize like these are human beings we
don't get out of life alive we all have
our troubles and our obstacles and the
things that we faced and had to overcome
it humanizes everybody and I I think
there's it's like this healing frequency
that comes out from
the screen that is unusual in our media
landscape right now and I think that's
why I personally like responded to it
and and you know not to down thank you
for saying all that not to downplay but
you know the show is not a cultural
phenomenon like in my mind I mean it's A
Hard Sell you know it's not my best
friend called me and said
you know the show is you I know you I
love it it's like I was crying watching
it
and yet I had to watch it like porn like
what are you talking about it's like
every time my wife came in I had to like
shut it off and she's like what are you
watching and there's no way I can watch
a show like that with my wife without
having an uncomfortable conversation
after and that's a conversation I don't
want to have and so maybe that's a
conversation he needs to have though
right well that's what I would say and
so I I sit there afterwards and I go oh
there's a lot of people that are saying
hey you know I watched that show alone
in my room and I go well why don't you
watch it with your husband or wife or
your parents or your kids and they're
like no thanks so there's there's people
you know when I had Erica garzon talking
about her addiction to masturbation and
porn
um I had another close friend say
you know I have monitoring software on
my kid's phone so I know how much my 15
year old watches porn it's like a lot
and yet I have no entry point on how to
have that conversation with him so I
said hey you want to watch Uncle Dave on
this TV show and it was uncomfortable as
hell you're talking about porn she you
know the woman's talking about porn and
I'm sitting there with my son and I know
he watches all the stuff he doesn't know
that I watch it and there's all this
shame coming up and yet because you put
that out into the world we were able to
have uh talk about that afterwards and I
was like that's awesome that's what it's
about man and even if that talk doesn't
happen it's like going to an AAA meeting
before you're ready to get sober like
you know you don't walk out of there and
get struck sober right but a seed is
planted and it's kind of like once
you've had been exposed to that like you
can't quite shake it right it's like
kind of ruminating around in your
Consciousness so I want to plant as many
seeds as I can and um
when someone goes hey have you tried
this new therapeutic you know EMDR or
you know whatever like psycho draw I go
I'm in enough said I'm I'm in and they
go well it's really expensive and it's
you know they don't let everyone in I go
so I've been to all these places and the
the ceiling that's always hit
is that
it's a business right it's like
you know whenever as they say in the
treatment like you have a breakthrough
right
it's like um
well how do you feel right now Dave I'm
gonna [ __ ] break all these cameras
right now well you can't do that
all right so I guess I you know I
thought I thought this was a safe place
I thought I could do whatever you know
um so I found that I was having these
amazing breakthroughs and I was watching
people who I thought would never have
breakthroughs like people that remind me
of my dad and people that remind me of
like my younger self having these
amazing breakthroughs and yet you're
still in an office building right you're
still sitting in chairs and I'm like
let's let's go outside and like and
they're like Dave this you know there's
a dentist office like you can't do do
that and I go
oh you can but I can I have creative
license I have artistic license I could
so
um you know I I tell everyone like I'm
not a guru I'm not a therapist even
though I've probably been in rooms with
group therapy one-on-one there you know
I've seen you know I've been at rehab
centers that are meant to be like 30
days 90 days and I've been there for two
years you know so I'll I'll have been
there when you're there and then six
months later I'll be like wait are you
married to and so I'll hear your wife's
side of the story and then I'll hear
your kids side of the story so I've I
have a lot of this information in my
head and I go oh wow like this is a lot
and I feel like
you know all the all the things that I
do of helping people donating money in
my time it's like
it never gets it's like oh you give a
home you know I'm like oh I give a
homeless guy some money and some clothes
and some food it's like he's
not making light of what I did I helped
him for that day for that moment but is
did that get to the root of it did that
get the the Brokenness and I go
How can I
you know it's like
as someone who has privilege who has
wealth like what is my best way to serve
myself and humanity and help one another
because
you get to
you know like when we had Trump as
president like man [ __ ] this guy he's a
horrible and it's like you know just as
well there's a broken child in there
there's a hurt child in there and and
does that is there any place in our
culture for a guy if he woke up the next
day and was like man
I've messed up I want to change it's
like no there's it's just kill that guy
like down with him yeah and so it's so
polarizing and even with myself
you know you get into any treatment you
know you go to Narcotics Anonymous and
it's like there's a hierarchy right it's
like oh well we're we're into opioids
and you all you do is smoke weed and you
know oh I I had more trauma than you and
this and that and I I sit there and I go
if if there's no room in our culture for
Redemption and change so I I as someone
who's is like me who is so judgmental
who is a hater I always try to lead with
love and and so
I've I've been asked to do
such hard things in my recovery you know
um
there's people that are you know in
recovery I I meet murderers and rapists
and people
that that are in prison still and
have done horrendous things who've
ripped people off and who who should be
in prison and so I'll meet them and I'll
be asked to sponsor them I'll be asked
to to work with them and I go absolutely
not like I
I think that person should burn in hell
and be in prison and they go
and
can you also help them
can you want them to burn in prison and
hell and also help them
and I go [ __ ] I got to think about that
because for you like uh if someone's out
there and they've been a horrible person
and they should be in prison and yet
they're not in prison and they're still
out
and they want to change is shaming them
and yelling at them
um so I I had I had these experiences
where I would meet people and I go and I
would be able to tell them I'd be like I
feel uncomfortable sitting next to you
right now I know you got out of prison
early I believe you should still be in
prison and should be there till till you
die
and yet because you're not in prison and
I'm not judge jury executioner
um I'm willing to work with you if you
are serious about changing because it
doesn't help for someone who's like that
to live in because he's just gonna be in
society worse and so as they say nothing
changes if nothing changes I
I was ready to sail off in the sunset
done with podcasting I don't like the
anxiety that comes with speaking behind
a microphone
um I don't need to be on TV all those
real things of why I you know before
they took those opportunities away
um
why I did um decide well what I was
deciding whether or not to do TV what I
did see in Bourdain what I did see what
Fame and workaholism did to him I was
like I'll just do the one-on-one thing
in private No cameras I don't need to
broadcast this I'll just help people the
way I help people and you know but
there's the ego and the workahols and
it's like but I need to help everyone I
gotta help the whole world like I need
to you know I gotta change everything
and and um you know I sat in it and I
already knew that there were there would
be no network that would show that show
so I went ahead and filmed it made it
myself
and then FX stepped in and their whole
logo is fearless you know and they they
said they didn't get involved
editorially with trying to there was a
little bit there was a little bit it was
a conversation I took uh the Louis deal
you know Louis CK uh you know created
edited did everything for less money so
I was like I'll take that deal I don't
need to get paid I never did this for
the money
um so I took less money for more
creative control
and um you know they were concerned you
know like all the no one else would sit
down with me
here's here's the thing that's about the
shame and and anonymity is
someone at all those companies knows who
I am they're like dude I love you on
Vice I love thumbs up I love but we just
can't do it and they go but we're not
gonna do it this show comes out the new
show
and I have some of the biggest
celebrities on the planet reach out to
me and they go dude I I don't even know
who you are but someone turned your show
on I watched all four episodes and I was
like cool can you can you be the next
guest can you tweet about and they're
like no no no this is really this is
just me privately telling you this and I
go oh okay so that's that's how deep
those things run and um you know I'm
forever grateful to everyone at FX
because they're they're so cool to work
with and they put out all these
challenging uh TV shows and stuff with
like the anti-hero and yeah they said
listen um
you know because the show was already
done they're like this is like this the
world needs to see this this is amazing
um we're just worried that like you
might get canceled or you know you've
you have such a crazy history of insane
things you've done and said and I was
like oh is that what you're worried
about that's easy for let me let me make
the decision for you hard pass on David
Joe
and and they go
I'm like didn't you like learn your
lesson with like Louie and all this
other stuff yeah yeah but also you have
a history of of doing that reverse Jiu
Jitsu maneuver where you know you take
it off the table and it just wants they
want it more I don't know if I was doing
I mean thank you for saying that I mean
that might not have been your motivation
but that's the psychological I just one
active I just wanted to know that
everyone had so I could be clear I'm
like everyone has now rejected me so now
I can just become a YouTuber right like
that's yeah that's I was like once
everyone has said no I mean it would
have been huge on YouTube if you'd done
that I mean and ultimately that's my I I
don't know maybe more people would have
seen it but it always comes down to this
and which is also the you know the
hesitancy to come here today is
when you do anything like that Outreach
recovery work something where you're
putting out a positive message showing
change
um you will help people
but then comes with that an expectation
you know and and when you spoke earlier
about
so the show is doing good and it was one
of my biggest fears talking to Neil
Strauss and other like really smart
brilliant people in recovery is
going to any of these behavioral places
and learning about addiction and
behavior you're going to learn all these
tools
and in the same way like learning the
force you can use it for the light or
the dark side so I've met people who are
like brilliant in recovery and yet their
lives are falling apart and they they go
into this martyr thing and like like I
you know I don't know Tony Robbins but
every time I see him speak I'm like
holy [ __ ] this guy is like brilliant and
he's he's so selfless and helping all
these people and he seems like a douche
you know it's like two things I'm like
it I'm like do would I ever want to be
that guy it's so weird like he's helping
so many people through and that's
priceless and that's invaluable and yet
yeah but your self-awareness around that
piece is the differentiator like you're
you have a conscious awareness that you
did that a fear like of of suddenly you
know kind of moving in that that kind of
weird Guru Direction and I don't see
that as a threat it just doesn't feel
like any part of your sensibility
whatsoever and you know what you had
said earlier
um was this piece about like thinking
about how you can be of service and like
yes you can you can be of service in a
one-on-one basis with you know that hard
case dude or whatever it is but
ultimately like when I look at you and I
think about
service more broadly like what is it
about you like what can you do that no
one else can do there's other people
with tons of money there's other people
that have more sobriety than you and
have been to more rehabs and are more
steeped in you know the literature of
psychology the one thing that you have
that no one else has is this very unique
artistic ability to express yourself in
a very particular way and and for you to
channel that in the direction like in
this in this vein of like gratitude and
service and and kind of raising the bar
on the kind of conversations that we can
have so we can help each other and heal
each other like that's a gift man and
that's why I think the show you know is
a reflection of your very particular
sensibility but to me it's coming from
that that place
and personally like selfishly like I
want to see you do more of that because
that's something nobody else can do
do you want me do you want to see me do
more of that or would you like to
participate in that no what I'm saying
is I want you to embrace that aspect of
who you are rather than resist it
I guess and to do it like with
everything that you've learned about
where your ego sits and what your
relationship to it is so that you don't
you know succumb to some of the things
that Tony did or fall prey to
workaholism and the like because the
thing is also recognizing but that's the
also the thing is recognizing I'm not
beyond that right just because I'm
healthy now it doesn't sure I could show
back into that but it's an opportunity
for you to reframe your relationship
with what you do and do it in a healthy
way rather than just create a boundary
and say I'm not going to do it because
it's too treacherous or dangerous
like is that a possibility for you the
you know that's you know I feel like as
they say you peel back the layers of the
onion I feel like
like today I'm not in crisis of all the
things that used to plague me and the
the like kind of final boss is the
workaholism you know there is a side of
me that loves to numb out and dis like
and of course in the spirit of helping
people right to spend less time with my
family and my and my friends and and
everything and I have a like an amazing
what I you know if you talk to me seven
years ago would consider a very boring
life but it's it's it's a purposeful
meaningful life it's um you know there's
times where things are hectic but you
know it's a pretty like mellow life in
that there's there's something deep in
within me that's like
why are you going to sleep right now you
there's so much more energy you can you
can pull an all-nighter right now
well you know now that you won't be
present for your family the next day
then but you can you can work on so many
projects right now you know you have
that capability like that's my Iron Man
right I cannot sleep no coffee no drugs
and work on 30 projects and start an art
show and an immersive experience and
develop other you know I can do that and
um you know just in the same way I
like
most of those interviews in my show were
from two years ago that's how long it
took to get that show onto TV it took
more work to get that on the TV than to
actually make the show and what happens
when you put the show out people go
when's the next season right ones I'm
like I worked on that with Paco and the
guys from the Philippines I mean we like
like I know it's not the way you do
normal TV but we did something on every
frame of that like there's so much stuff
that we put in there subliminally and
hidden messages and stuff that there's a
lot of thought put into it and people to
go someone's like I'm like how about sit
with the thing that we made and like is
one season enough does there have to be
a season two and
and these types of things so I'm
I'm trying like I'm impulsive you know I
like to just make decisions without
thinking about it and to
you know
once again that whole thing with like
waiting in line like I don't like
waiting I don't like sitting in silence
I don't like I have to just run I have
to just get to the next thing so
um to sit here and be like
um
like you said all this reframing and re
re-measuring these things
um
because
I did a show
um in an office building about three
four years ago where I had to fight
against my ego and
tell people you can't bring your phone
in you know and I was like well then how
are people going to see it online and
it's like well maybe just the people
that come see it that's that's enough
you know and and um
and so and another thing is can you
really experience something truly when
there's thousands of people coming
through there so I limited it to groups
of seven
and and you went in through the whole
show with like a guide and I implemented
like all these things that I learned and
um and I was part of the show too
and it was the first
um phase of the Cho show
and
I had no
I had no idea how much that was gonna
take out of me like physically and and
spirit like emotionally like
um you know because at the end of the
day you know we had a hundred people a
day coming in through the show when we
could have had thousands and and I had
um a staff of like hundreds of people
like this is just financially not viable
in in a treatment center right like if
you went to a treatment center and you
have like a few therapists and you have
your group this like I had a team of
like hundreds of people catering to just
you and
some of these people would just be on
the floor crying all night so I had to
find therapists to treat the staff after
and meaning somebody comes in for this
experience and they're they're exposed
to some form of yeah you would fill out
a version of what you experienced in
treatment right so I went through yeah
and I went for years and I go people
aren't going to take years off to do
this so I'm gonna try to fit it into a
four-hour experience right and um it was
um
I mean it it floored me I I
I it took so much out of me and yet
um you know the show cost me a
tremendous amount of money and and I
could have monetized it I could have
charged people and people would have
gladly paid and after the show
um there's a guy who lent me use of the
building for free and he's a billionaire
and he's he you know when I told him
originally what I was going to use the
show for he's like Dave I like that
you're giving back and I'm gonna give
you a great price and I was like
you just give it to me for free he's
like that's not how business works you
don't just I go well you're rich and I'm
rich and I why don't you just like I
just told you I'm doing this to help
people and he's like
I like how blunt you are okay so he let
me use that building for free and at the
end of it his entire family had gone
through and he's like when you were
explaining it to me I didn't get it but
now that we've gone through and I've
seen it bring my family closer together
let's take this show on the road I got
buildings you know he's a real estate
guy I got buildings in every city in the
world and um like and so my workaholsom
goes this is going to be a hit show like
let's and I and I had to sit there and
it took out you know it's it's almost
embarrassing to say it took like seven
people in my life to like sit me down
and be like look at how messed up you
are right now you just put everything
into helping and entertaining and doing
all this stuff for these people
and you have to respect what a psychic
told that took on you and so we get it
that you can like disassociate and just
take this show on the road for the next
couple years
but
in a in a and you know with all the
things you learn can you be kind to
yourself um because I don't even know
what that means because my whole life
I've treated myself the same way like if
I think about the most verbally and
physically abusive girlfriends I've had
that's how I treat myself I talk down to
myself I say I'm no good
and so I don't want to sit in that so I
I go so me taking a vacation after this
would be kind to myself and they're like
yeah yeah like you've just did a lot of
heavy lifting but in my mind I go but it
was only 2 000 people it should have
been you know 200 000 people and it's
always that it's like I wanna I wanna
help everyone and as long as I'm helping
people I never have to help myself I can
focus on helping everyone but myself
right it just becomes a way to avoid or
deflect right that peace that's the
hardest which is learning to love
yourself yeah
and uh yeah it was it was um
yeah so I'm here today and and my life's
quite simple and I you know it's all
these this is the way recovery was
explained to me
the concept of getting better is very
simple it's not complicated right I just
conscious contact with your higher power
service work blocking your phone like
there's action exercising you know um
eating healthy these are all like none
of these are like hard Concepts to
understand but it's hard it's simple but
it's very hard like it's gonna take me
uh an incredible amount of willpower
after this interview to drive home
without stopping at Burger King like
that's just the truth give you a ride
yeah should get me to the next exit and
then uh I'll escort you out of here yeah
you can do it
thank you you just you just saying that
like you can do it you can do it that's
a nice positive it's definitely within
your power
yeah man I'll let you know if uh mission
accomplished or not we'll see
well uh you know we should round this
out but I I don't want to let you go
without
you know maybe a few words for for
um the one who still suffers the one
being the many because I think there's a
lot of people who
you know struggle in Silence with some
form of compulsive Behavior or addiction
to substance or process in some way I
mean I just feel like this is the you
know problem of our age like it's just
metastasizing like crazy so whether it's
gambling or food or phones or sex or
shopping or drugs and alcohol whatever
it is like I feel like almost all of us
struggles in one way or the other along
this very broad spectrum and finding a
way out is really hard for most people
so for the one who's still suffering
right now I just want to tell you
once again I don't want to make it about
race but I've been to
you know you guys have heard me now I've
been to all these treatment facilities
I've seen in seven years of treatment
two other Asian people it's not part of
our culture
um and the last one almost threw me out
because it was my voice speaking to me
in the form of another kid I was at a
meeting and a kid came in and he was
Korean and he saw me and he I could tell
right away he recognized me and at the
end of the meeting he's like
Dave Cho
you're rich you're famous you what are
you doing here like like I wasn't and as
he was saying that in my head I was like
you're right what am I doing here I'm
better than this and and that almost
took me out I was like I don't need to
be here I am better than these people
so if you're listening now and no
judging I don't care what video games
porn
uh the internet YouTube binge watching
TV food whatever your thing is no
judging
the same brain that got you into this
mess is not the one that's going to get
you out
you need a hand and all those tools all
these Electronics all these things that
are used for evil and and to and to numb
you and and distract you you can use
those same tools to
you know I've been to these places that
cost money but there's so much free
services there's literally a 12-step
program for every addiction
and if you think you are any of these
things you just am I a workaholic just
type in characteristics of a workaholic
and you'll see if you are very quickly
um you probably are because we live in a
nation everyone goes hey America is a
nation of immigrants right but that all
that means is We're a nation of
Workaholics because we came everyone
came here for something better and that
means work your ass off so even if
you're not a workaholic your family's
workaholic
and um all these things
we it's not it's not going to be you on
your phone alone watching porn alone
playing video games alone it's through
connection and so reach out ask for help
tell someone
you know as as as you know when when you
ask anyone in society hey man how are
you doing most people will give you the
answer fine good okay all of which
aren't emotions that's our our automatic
response I'm okay I mean you could have
the worst thing happening in your life
today and be like I'm fine I'm okay so
to just
it's okay you're not okay
um and that doesn't mean like you're not
going to be okay forever you just ask
for help there's support and as someone
you know my life today I can't get
through it without this you know I have
I'm part of a men's group I I go to
12-step meetings regularly on Zoom which
is the easiest it's ever been it's
there's kind of a disconnect with the
zoom but still better than nothing I
have a therapist that I see and it's
like there's a part of my attic brain
that's like
you need to go talk to someone once a
week for an hour about you know and I go
do you know how much time I spend in
casinos and at strip clubs and like all
these places like I can't spend one hour
a week on myself
so
um there's help out there it's not
hopeless and I wish for all my friends
that
killed themselves and for the times in
my life where I contemplated suicide and
you know
I mean we live in a society where it's
normalized where it's more okay to kill
yourself than to ask for help that's
where we're at now
someone would rather murder themselves
than to go hey man I'm really having a
tough time
uh stopping watching television or or or
whatever your problem is it there's
there's no judging
um and we need it we're not equipped to
deal with
what's happening in the world so the way
we get through it is through connection
and um
you know all these social media all
these things were invented to connect
and we're more disconnected than we've
ever been
so um and I guess I'll just because I'm
with you right now are you suffering
today from anything
um
a little bit you know I'm over tired I'm
over committed I have been working too
hard uh
I won't challenge you to the race then
today the the person today but I'll
challenge you
[Music]
um
I I can like predict what I think will
happen but uh you said uh not a year and
you have you know I'm you know your
podcast is growing the way I heard about
it is you're worshiped at uh Sierra
Tucson and all these like uh they listen
to you religiously
so it's like weird it's like oh man I'm
getting bigger better guess and
it's intoxicating
um so having a healthy relationship with
that so I challenge you to take six
months off yeah and spend time that's a
heavy challenge it's a heavy challenge
but I know you're up for it and you've
done heavier things I can guarantee you
you won't lose one fan one listener when
you come back in six months you may have
more fans more listeners
um it doesn't mean these guys can't keep
working they could
re-cut best doves or whatever
more time focusing on yourself your
family
and um
it's it'll change your life yeah
I'm not going to commit to that right
now but it's a challenge but what I will
commit to is I'm gonna think about that
and I'm gonna do that like like honestly
and do an inventory around that because
I think that's insightful
um
thanks man thank you man yeah how do you
feel
I feel
um
hmm
I feel calm
I feel
um
less than a little bit not a lot just
because
I have well you kind of said it's like
you're like I kind of expected you to
come in hot you know and that's usually
what I do I don't meditate I like get
myself like kind of amped up it's like I
take um I take podcasting and
broadcasting very seriously I hate when
people just show up and dial it in like
um I was up last night I had like tons
of material and stuff I I barely touched
on any of it but
um
I kind of uh
you know my closest friends don't watch
anything I do because they go you're
kind of gross because you you go into
this cartoon character of who you are
and we know the real you so but there's
that always part of me that's always
wanting to be like
um I don't know who Rich has had on here
but when I come in here I gotta [ __ ]
blow them away and this has got to be
the best show he ever does and it's a
performance but I mean so my thinking
going into it was he's gonna come in
like that and my job's gonna be to
figure out how to get him to get him
past that you know oh no you came in
passed it already well because the way I
learned about you is all all people in
recovery were like you got to listen to
this guy ritual and like you you won't
the way you go on to these other shows
you have to kind of school them on what
addiction is and mental health and he's
like he's already you don't have to
explain things to him so you can just be
yourself and that's like
um there's something liberating about
that like I can just be yeah but then um
you know there's always
you know
everyone I interviewed on my show was
close you know the the the the the
shortest ones would be three hours but
they would go plus six hours usually and
um
that's my workaholism of
it took me years for me to have
breakthroughs but I'm trying to get a
breakthrough within six hours so I'm
like
why the [ __ ] does this guy run so much
why does he like who what like if
someone put a gun to my head and said
you need to run an ultra marathon or
your entire family is going to be
murdered I'd be like just murder my
family right now like that's that's the
same equivalent of I can't run a 5k like
it's like my legs start hurting I go
okay I'm gonna stop because this hurts
so the best like you said all the best
Runners are in recovery and they're
covered in tattoos it's like what are
you running away from the pain of
something the the the amazing ability to
completely disassociate your mind from
your body so that you can I mean like
for me when I see that I go that's
definitely you got to be in shape and
physical but it's more mental Than
Physical it's mental but just to flip
the lens on that the other side of that
coin is that when you put yourself in
that position of trying to do something
really hard you meet yourself in a very
fundamental way like you can't run away
from Who You Are are and your character
gets revealed your weaknesses your
proclivities like all of the looping in
your mind like you become very present
with all of that and I think it creates
a greater awareness
of kind of what you're dealing with so
you can deconstruct it and move forward
like that's the positive aspect of that
because I got into this at a very
difficult time in my life where I was
confused about who I was and what I
wanted to be I'd been sober right it's
not like I went I got sober and
immediately jumped into this like I'd
been sober for 10 years before I got
into it but I was reaching another
like Plateau or kind of inflection point
in my growth and
what I found through the process of of
like really submersing myself in that
subculture is I learned a lot about who
I am and I learned you know what I
needed to look at where I was still like
all of these blind spots that I've been
hiding from suddenly like percolate up
to the surface so those things that
you're running away from like come up
right it's so scary but it's an
opportunity and I'm not saying I've
overcome all of those things but I
definitely have a greater awareness of
them and I've been able to kind of
overcome some of them
so wow it sounds scary yeah so that you
you explaining that to me so it's like
you telling me I need to take six months
off is like me telling you you need to
train for a 50 mile run or something
like that
[Music]
50 miles what's the marathon 26.96
[ __ ] I've never got it never in my life
two years to do it
so if I run a marathon and and you give
me a two year time limit in that time or
after you'll take six months I'll take
six months off
that's a challenge I can't even imagine
like when anyone explains me like what
they need to do to do a marathon it's
that to me sounds like mental illness I
go that doesn't sound healthy yeah
um but that's you putting a cap on your
own capabilities do you know how much
your life will like expand but like the
thing is you think by taking a six month
break you'll lose stuff like oh I'll
lose sponsors I'll lose my flow I'll
lose like whatever momentum I had but
it's just the way my life has grown from
taking a year off is like insane you
know like I have more opportunities more
you know because we live in a society
where
it's moving so quickly you just kind of
want to say yes to things and go oh okay
cool let's like and then you get sort of
or at least I should use I statements I
get taken for a ride where I'm like do
it like right now
you know what I'm gonna I'm about to
have a conversation about season two and
it's like there's no part of my brain
that's like oh of course they offer you
season two you just take it you know
without even considering like well is
that even something that you should do
you know so
um yeah I guess my feeling when you ask
me how I'm feeling right now is
I bring so much
um weight to every interview and podcast
that I do that um
you know
I I I was I left very
um and this is part of my growth uh
disappointed in every single interview I
did on my show and it's just like unless
I had the level of breakthrough that I
did for years I mean you're creating a
ridiculous expectation for yourself and
also the it's like I I
um you know I know rain just did your
show and he's been asking me to do his
podcast and I'm in a men's group with
rain I don't think he would mind and so
I I we have a shared vocabulary where we
talk in shorthand like I don't have to
explain things and I go
um he's like yeah come on and talk about
art I'm like so boring like is that
really what you want he's like yeah
where creativity comes from I'm like
[ __ ] that like I'm like how about you
know because I know his father passed
away how about I play your dad and
because I know you're and he's like I
don't know if I want to do that I'm
gonna pull a Cho show all right I wanna
that's what I want to do everywhere I go
yeah and I have to have people
constantly explain to me like that's
really heavy that's really deep like I'm
like let's go there let's I want to find
I want to find that with um other people
but it's like the impatience of like I
want it now it's like well why don't you
why don't you build up to that you know
um
so I guess it's uh unrealistic
expectations and then and then uh
sadness and then shame and then Burger
King and then shame with overeating then
driving home and then
you know I'm gonna google like what it
takes to run a marathon and be like that
I'm never gonna and then I just sit
there and I'm like I'm a loser like how
you know we're gonna feed you a little
bit I'm gonna escort you out of here I'm
gonna give you a training plan I'm gonna
figure out how I'm gonna take six months
off and in the interim man I'm gonna uh
send you a bunch of Grace thank you man
yeah same to you man appreciate you I
appreciate the uh honesty today man and
sharing space with me thanks
all right buddy peace peace
[Music]